Yang paling kecil kayak Kaisang itu ya
jualan pisang goreng. Kemudian yang apa
yang gede Gibran itu apa? Ee jualan
martabak.
Ini yang Ayang sama suaminya mau jualan
kopi ya silakanlah. Mau terjun ke
politik juga silakan. Enggak tahu. Saya
tanyakan aja ke anaknya langsung.
Ibrat
salat.
Hibrat.
Terima kasih.
Yuk, balik ke mana nih? Ar
pulang
pulang semu
balik sampai
tidur
ya kadang-kadang enggak sesuai
yang diinginkan.
Abang pulang
Jogja langsung
mm mungkin ke bandara malam.
Oke.
Okelah sampai ketemu.
Oke thank you ya.
Mbak
sampai ketemu.
Sampai ketemu.
Bye.
Oke, Pak.
Y
setahun terakhir ini dia ngajar di
kampus. Kampus saya Fakultas Hukum UGM
juga ngajar di beberapa tempat ya.
mengajar, nguji, melakukan penelitian,
ee menulis ya kerjaan-kerjaan sebagai
seorang dosen.
Setahun terakhir ini pasti ngajar karena
memang itu kerjaan saya sebagai dosen.
Ngajar, melakukan penelitian pasti
nulis. Saya punya kolom rutin juga di
dua media massa. Ee jadi disibukkannya
dengan menulis dan mengajar.
1 tahun terakhir ini seperti biasa saya
mengajar di kampus dan melakukan
berbagai penelitian.
Biasanya antara mengajar dan meneliti
ada korelasinya karena saya melihat
antara teori dan praktik yang terjadi.
[Musik]
Apa
itu? Kopi ya
profesor.
Eh siapa
Jonjon?
[Musik]
Halo. Halo.
Sip. Thank you. Thank you.
Kok di sini ya?
Apa kabar, Bib? Senjata
baik-baik. Ramai tadi di acara itu.
Iya. Eh, selamat
selamat, Pak.
Siapa yang diselamatin? Yang sini apa
yang situ?
Habibi ituelamin belum?
Itu bolehlah kita sebut-sebut sedikit.
Oke. R3 saya
sihat, Pak.
hari ini.
Iya.
By the way, Feri jaket gasnya lama.
Iya. Yang baru cuman ini rezim sama
status guru besarnya dia. Heorin
dibocorin juga.
Asik
ya, Mas.
I ready kami semua. Ready
ya. Siap
ya. Mudah-mudahan ya. Mudah-mudahan
lancar
kita jelasin.
Amin.
Amin. Amin.
Banyak hal yang baru di republik ini.
Jadi ya harus kita coba jelasin.
Kami tunggu kejutan dari kalian semua.
Asik
ya.
Siap. Thank you, Mas.
Bang,
akhirnya kita bikin film lagi.
Film
akhirnya setelah lama menunggu enggak
sabar.
Benar. Akhirnya kita bikin film lagi,
film Dirty Vote 2. Kalau di Dirty Vote 1
sebenarnya kami menggambarkan bahwa ada
semacam kecurangan sistematis di balik
kemenangan 88 58% yang dipegang oleh
Prabowo dan Gibran. Kecurangan
sistematis itu membuat sebenarnya
Prabowo dan Gibran juga merasa insecure.
Dia merasa tidak percaya diri. Karena
dia tidak merasa percaya diri maka
kemudian dia membangun apa yang akan
kita istilahkan. Dalam hampir seluruh
dari eh acara Derivot ini sebenarnya
adalah otot 3 O, otot, lalu kemudian
otak, dan ongkos. Otot itu lebih pada
sesuatu yang bersifat hardware
barangkali penggunaan kekerasan lalu
penggunaan ee kekuatan yang koersif.
Otak itu bicara soal sesuatu yang lebih
ee merangkul parpol agar parlemen tanpa
oposisi. Begitu juga ongkos. Nah, kalau
otot itu kira-kira dia banyak membiarkan
polisi untuk makin berkuasa lalu
kemudian mengembalikan militarisme. Yang
kedua, otak dia merangkul parpol agar
parlemen tanpa oposisi termasuk produk
hukumnya untuk memperkuat rezim dan
ongkos tentu saja adalah gentong babi
untuk para elit oligarki hingga masa
pemilih. Ya, di bagian dua kita akan
bicara soal apa tujuan dari menggunakan
3 O tadi, otot, otak, dan ongkos. Ketiga
tujuan itu tentu saja pertama sekali
adalah memenangkan pemilu karena sudah
pernah dilakukan.
Yang kedua, memastikan wujudnya
kapitalisme terpimpin yang tentu saja
berupaya mengendalikan banyak
kepentingan. Dan bagaimana kemudian itu
semua bisa diwujudkan? Tentu salah satu
langkahnya dengan upaya kembali ke
Undang-Undang Dasar 45 ala Orde Baru.
Sebab undang-undang ini pula yang
membuat kekuasaan otoritarianisme bisa
langgeng di Indonesia.
dan semua punya kepentingan besar untuk
mewujudkan ini, terutama
kaum oligark yang diuntungkan dari
mekanisme yang tidak demokratis itu.
Lalu kelompok ini tentu saja saling
menyokong. Uang dibutuhkan oleh ee
politik untuk memenangkan pemilu dan
lain-lain. Inilah yang menjadi lingkaran
setan di dalam sistem politik
ketatanegaraan kita. Nah, nanti Mbak
Bibip akan bicara chapter 3.
Iya, soalnya kan lingkaran setan masa
enggak kita putus.
Pasti dong harus diputus. Kalau enggak
sampai kapan kita mau begini terus?
Jadi, ada paling tidak tiga hal yang
kita harus lihat. Pertama, reformasi
kepolisian. Yang kedua, reformasi TNI.
Dua-duanya karena ini sifatnya
institusional,
ya. kita
harus bongkar supaya kita bisa
mengembalikan fungsi otot tadi untuk
kepentingan negara.
H.
Dan kemudian yang ketiga adalah
perombakan sistem politik. Dan di sini
tuh ada partai politik juga ada sistem
pemilu. Kita harus bongkar juga supaya
otak dan ongkos itu dikembalikan kepada
rakyat. Jadi nanti di ujung kita akan
membongkar lingkaran setan ini untuk
menciptakan sistem politik yang lebih
inklusif. Jadi kita semua bisa ikut
dalam politik ini, bukan hanya
mereka-mereka ini.
Dan juga supaya kita enggak perlu bikin
3.
Enggak perlu lah.
Oke, silakan, Bang. Jabarkan.
Silakan dimulai.
Saya mulai duluan, ya.
Sip.
Oke.
Ajar.
I. Kita semua tahu Prabowo dan Gibran
memenangkan pemilu presiden 2024.
Prabowo memenangkan 58,6%
sedangkan Anis dan Muhaimin itu berada
di angka 24,9
serta pasangan Ganjar Mahfud ND itu
berada di 16,5. Suka atau tidak suka,
pasangan Prabowo Gibran kemudian
dilantik menjadi presiden.
Pengucapan sumpah Presiden Republik
Indonesia.
Bismillahirrahmanirrahim.
Demi Allah, saya bersumpah
akan memenuhi kewajiban Presiden
Republik Indonesia
dengan sebaik-baiknya
dan seadil-adilnya.
memegang teguh Undang-Undang Dasar dan
menjalankan
segala undang-undang dan peraturannya
dengan selurus-lurusnya
serta berbakti kepada nusa dan bangsa.
Jika kita lihat kemenangan 58%
yang dipegang oleh Prabowo Gibran
betulkah lurus dengan angka dukungan
publik? Memang survei approval rate bagi
Prabowo di 100 hari itu adalah 80,9.
Tetapi jangan lupa bahwa sebenarnya di
akhir masa jambatan ee Joko Joko Widodo
sebenarnya dia sudah mendapatkan 75,6%
dan kita tahu ada relasi yang kuat
antara Prabowo dan Joko Widodo. Itu
sebabnya 80,9 tadi sebenarnya tidak
benar-benar murni karena spare-nya
kalaupun ada penambahan itu hanya ada
5%. Kita bisa bandingkan dengan yang
terjadi di peralihan antara Susilo
Bambang Widyono ke Joko Widodo. Di Juni
2014, approval rate Susilo Bambang
Yudoyono sebenarnya 48%. Tapi Joko
Widodo di 100 harinya itu dapat
meningkatkan sampai 65,1%
dan itu berarti sekitar hampir 17%
perbedaan approval rate. Ini yang kita
mau bilang sebenarnya bahwa ada semacam
paradoks. Ada semacam paradoks bahwa
tingkat survei yang tinggi, tingkat
approval rate yang tinggi sebenarnya
tidak ditunjang dengan rasa percaya diri
ketika mengkonversi itu menjadi
kebijakan-kebijakan dalam kebijakan
negara.
Belum setahun sebenarnya kalau kita
lihat belum setahun sudah terjadi
rentetan peristiwa yang menjadi pemicu
kemarahan rakyat Indonesia. Kita mulai
dari November ada kenaikan PPN 12% yang
kemudian harus direvisi segera. Ada
efisiensi anggaran yang punya komplikasi
yang tidak sederhana ke banyak hal. ada
redistribusi atau mengulang cara
mendistribusikan kembali LPG 3 kg di
pengecer dan itu berakibat cukup parah.
Belum lagi ada kasus Danantara atau
negara membuat danantara dan itu
mengalami banyak catatan. Juga ada
penolakan TNI, rancangan Undang-Undang
TNI. juga ada dua tagar yang sempat
menjadi heboh dan kisruh karena penuh ee
komentar dan termasuk dikomentari oleh
Presiden. Belum lagi kenaikan PBB yang
terjadi di beberapa daerah dan akhirnya
memicu demonstrasi yang besar. Kita juga
bisa lihat ada persoalan soal blokir
dana idle oleh PPATK yang berbuah juga
begitu banyak catatan. Dan tentu saja
yang tidak bisa kita lepaskan adalah apa
yang terjadi di prahara.
Agustus 2025.
Nah, mari kita jelaskan satu persatu
prahara tersebut. Kalau kita lihat yang
pertama, Presiden Probowo menerbitkan
Impress efisiensi tahun 2025. APBN
kemudian dipangkas sampai 306 triliun.
Kita menyokong efisiensi. Tapi pada saat
yang sama efisiensi yang tidak mendasar
itu kemudian banyak terkena ke
kebijakan-kebijakan lainnya sehingga
menjalannya kebijakan publik, jalannya
pemerintahan itu menjadi terhalang.
Begitu juga ada kebijakan menghentikan
eceran LPG 3 kg yang membuat masyarakat
harus antri sangat luar biasa.
Dan bahkan kita harus mesti ingat ada
satu orang yang meninggal dan
ditenggarai itu keterkaitannya dengan
mengantri BBM yang LPG yang sangat
panjang.
tidak lama berselang, pemerintah juga
mengucurkan danantara, meluncurkan
danantara untuk menghimpun dana. Banyak
sekali perdebatan karena ada keterkaitan
mengenai ee cara, kemudian model dan
lain-lain sebagainya.
Belum. Kemudian juga tidak lama
berselang lagi, masih dalam 1 tahun yang
sama. Rasa insecure itu barangkali bisa
kita lihat bagaimana
aksi masyarakat sipil menolak ROO yang
kemudian bisa kita lihat dari video ini.
Selamat sore Bapak Ibu. Kami dari
koalisi reformasi sektor keamanan,
pemerhati di bidang pertahanan. Kami
menuntut agar proses pembahasan revisi
undang-undang ini dihentikan karena
tidak sesuai dengan proses legislasi
ini. Diadakan tertutup Bapak, Ibu. Eh,
Pak,
Pak.
Woi, Anda mendorong, Teman-teman.
Bagaimana kita kemudian hari ini
represif? Kami menjalankan fungsi
pengawasan sebagai masyarakat sipil.
Kami menolak adanya pembahasan di dalam.
Kami menolak adanya DUI fungsi ABRI,
Teman-teman.
penolakan itu sebenarnya mudah untuk
mengaitkannya betapa negara mengalami
rasa insecure dan ini barangkali kenapa
kemudian ada dua tagar yang luar biasa
keluar viral dalam jangka waktu cukup
lama khususnya berbicara soal Indonesia
gelap lalu kemudian tagar lain adalah
kabur aja dulu dua tagar ini sebenarnya
menggambarkan keinginan publik
menggambarkan partisipasi publik tapi
coba bayang
ya bagaimana negara kemudian melihat
tagar ini.
Anda bisa lihat dari bagaimana Prabowo
menyampaikan pandangannya soal tagar
kedua tagar itu.
Ada orang-orang yang
berperan
sebagai orang pintar, berperan sebagai
pemimpin, tapi yang di yang disebarkan
adalah pesimisme.
Indonesia gelap,
kabur aja deh.
Lu kabur aja lu.
Emang gampang lu di situ. Di luar negeri
di mana lu? Lu dikejar-kejar di situ
ini
dan ternyata memang ini adalah rekayasa.
Ini dibuat-buat.
Kami selalu membayangkan sebenarnya
bahasa-bahasa ini lahir dari rasa
insecure, rasa kemudian untuk tidak
percaya diri. Nah, tidak hanya berhenti
di situ. Kita jangan lupa ada kasus
pemangkasan anggaran besar-besaran yang
terjadi karena dengan berbagai dalih
tapi kemudian memiliki dampak pada
berkurangnya dana transfer daerah. Dan
transfer daerah yang berkurang ini
memaksa daerah untuk kreatif, tetapi
kemudian kreatifnya itu berakibat
kenaikan pajak bumi dan bangunan yang
dicari sebagai solusi yang dikerjakan
oleh pemerintah daerah. Serta kebijakan
itu kemudian menuai protes yang sangat
luar biasa.
Setidaknya protes itu terjadi di begitu
banyak daerah. Meskipun barangkali yang
kita bisa lihat wakili jadi potret
besarnya itu adalah apa yang terjadi
Pati Cirebon maupun Bon
kan menetapkan tanah terlantau itu kan
butuh waktu 587
hari tidak serta-merta
jadi tidak asal tetapkan tetapkan tidak
bisa jadi kalau sampai segini sudah
dikasih surat cinta apa memang dia
kemudian protes berarti memang yang
bersangkutan itu punya enggak punya niat
niat untuk mendaya gunakan dan
memanfaatkan tanahnya. Tapi perlu
diketahui ya tanah itu tidak ada yang
memiliki. Yang memiliki tanah itu
negara.
Orang itu hanya menguasai
negara kemudian memberikan hak
kepemilikan kepada Jadi enggak ada
istilah tanah kalau belum ada SHM-nya
itu dia memiliki enggak ada.
Oh ini tanahnya mbah-mbah saya leluhur
saya. Saya mau tanya, memang mbahmu
dulumu dulu bisa membuat tanah?
Sekali lagi, rasa insecure itu berakibat
ada paradigma yang dibuat secara
asal-asalan. Dan seperti yang saya
sampaikan tadi, kebijakan itu kemudian
dicabut
dan akhirnya dia minta maaf.
Nah, lanjut lagi. Tidak lama berselang
kita bicara juga soal ketenangan publik
yang kembali terusik oleh kebijakan
PPATK. Jadi, PPATK mengeluarkan
kebijakan untuk melakukan semacam
pemblokiran terhadap dana-dana di
berbagai ee bank yang idle lebih dari 3
bulan. Dan itu tentu saja karena
kemudian berakibat sangat signifikan
kepada publik, memicu keparahan publik.
Apa yang kita mau sampaikan sekali lagi
dari pengantar sederhana ini sebenarnya
belum 1 tahun ada begitu banyak
kebijakan kontroversi.
Ada yang diperbaiki dan ada yang tetap
lanjut. Ada yang diperbaiki karena
viral, tapi ada yang kemudian eh dibuat
serampangan meskipun dengan begitu
banyak kritikan.
Sekali lagi, legitimasi rendah membuat
Prabowo Gibran merasa insecure, merasa
terancam. Saking merasa insecure-nya,
kita bisa lihat bagaimana Prabowo kerap
melontarkan narasi pembelaan yang
seakan-akan seperti insinuatif,
seakan-akan seperti melakukan tuduhan
dengan menggambarkan seolah-olah ada
musuh bersama, yaitu ada pihak asing
atau kemudian ee teror atau kemudian
pihak-pihak yang tidak menginginkan
negara menjadi lebih baik.
Ada
segelintir orang, ada saya kira mereka
entah sadar atau tidak sadar mereka ya
itu sudah jadi antek-antek asing.
Enggak apa-apa saya bicara di depan
wartawan. Saya katakan mereka sadar atau
mereka antek asing. Mereka tidak suka
Indonesia bangkit. Mereka tidak suka
Indonesia bangkit. Saya katakan mereka
tidak suka Indonesia bangkit. Tapi kita
yang akan bangkit bersama Indonesia.
Biar anjing menggonggong, kafilah tetap
akan terus.
Kalau kita lihat ya lagi-lagi rasa
insecure itu kemudian keluar dengan
berbagai em apa narasi seakan-akan
koruptor lalu kemudian seakan-akan ee
ada neg ada orang yang tidak suka pada
bangsa ini. Padahal sebenarnya menurut
kami lagi-lagi itu adalah bagian rasa
insecure
koruptor-koruptor itu yang biayai
demo-demo itu.
Indonesia gelap.
Sorie ya.
[Tepuk tangan]
Indonesia cerah.
Masa depan Indonesia cerah.
Saya sudah lihat angka-angkanya.
Kekayaan kita luar biasa. Tinggal kita
bisa mengelola atau tidak. Tinggal kita
berani atau tidak.
Ini yang saya bilang tadi bahwa ada
semacam insinuasi yang dilakukan. Lalu
kemudian persis yang saya katakan
sebelumnya juga ada semacam ketakutan
berlebihan terhadap simbol One Piece.
Bahkan negara kemudian mengatakan
seakan-akan orang yang mengebarkan
mengibarkan bendera One Piece itu bisa
dipidana. Satu perdebatan yang tentu
saja sangat besar. soal mungkin atau
tidaknya
tidak berhenti di sini ya. Kalau kita
perhatikan juga terjadi apa yang disebut
secara ee teori barangkali adalah
rasa insecure itu coba dikonversi
menjadi semacam ingin membuat
mistifikasi.
Ingin membuat mistifikasi untuk
mengaburkan sejarah. Kenapa sejarah
menjadi penting? Karena Prabowo dan
Gibran ini mewarisi sejarah yang tidak
terlalu baik. ada catatan kelam
barangkali berkaitan dengan rezim Orde
Baru dan juga berkaitan dengan apa yang
terjadi di tahun '98. Dan itu sebabnya
menteri yang sekaligus orang kepercayaan
Prabowo itu kemudian mendorong
mistifikasi itu caranya dengan apa?
Mengubah alur sejarah.
Alur sejarah coba diubah dan tidak
berhenti di situ juga didorong untuk
segera memasukkan Soeharto untuk menjadi
pahlawan nasional.
Saya balik pada apa yang saya jelaskan
di awal soal 3O.
Dari sini kemudian rasa insecure itu
memaksa Prabowo Gibran untuk segera
melakukan 3O. Pertama tentu saja adalah
memperkuat otot.
Apa yang kami bayangkan sebenarnya dari
memperkuat otot itu? Sebenarnya ini
dalam konteks sesuatu yang eh koersif,
hard power ya. Sedangkan otak barangkali
itu adalah sesuatu yang lebih soft.
bicara soal ganti aturan dan aliansi
politik serta kedua-duanya membutuhkan
ongkos. di tingkat soal otot kalau kita
lihat ya bicara soal bagaimana dia
menguatkan ee polisi kepolisian dengan
cara
memegang pucuk pimpinan itu secara
sangat erat sigit listiosit
kalau kita lihat dalam sejarah presiden
eh presiden pasca reformasi
ltioigit menjadi kapol Polri yang paling
lama. Ia memegang jabatan ini hampir 5
tahun. Ya, 5 tahun itu bukan soal
sesuatu yang pendek. Karena kalau kita
bandingkan misalnya dengan
Kapolri terbaik yang pernah dimiliki
oleh republik ini bahkan hanya kitaran 3
tahun.
Pertanyaannya pasti, betulkah Listio
sebaik Hugel?
Nah, tidak berhenti kalau kita bicara
soal ee personil, polisi juga dibiarkan
merangkap jabatan
di banyak posisi yang sebenarnya tentu
saja itu perdebatan, perdebatan yang
panjang bisakah dipegang oleh polisi.
Jadi ada upaya memperkuat otot politik
dan membiarkan kemewahan-kemewahan yang
sudah dimiliki oleh kepolisian sejak
lama semenjak zaman Jokowi tentu saja
itu dibiarkan ada. Kalau kita lihat
secara langsung dari gambar ini ada 52
perwira aktif yang rangkap jabatan
sipil. Ada yang jadi irjen di
Kementerian UMKM, ada yang jadi irjen di
Kementerian ESDM, ada yang menjadi
tenaga ahli Menpora, Badan Penyelenggara
Haji. Bahkan ada yang dapat penugasan
menjadi Sekjen di Dewan Perwakilan
Daerah Republik Indonesia.
Ada juga em kita bicara soal KOMDI untuk
pengawasan ruang digital hingga urusan
penegakan keadilan dan rekonsiliasi
Kementerian ee Koordinasi Pembangunan
dan Kebudayaan.
Bayangkan ada 52 orang. Padahal di dalam
Undang-Undang Undang-Undang Polri jelas
dikatakan di pasal 28-nya
anggota kepolisian negara Republik
Indonesia dapat menduduki jabatan di
luar kepolisian setelah mengundurkan
diri atau pensiun dari Dinas Kepolisian.
tidak hanya berhenti di level menguatkan
personil, apa yang dilakukan juga adalah
melakukan penguatan Polri melalui
rancangan undang-undang Polri yang saya
kira sudah beredar cukup lama di publik
ya. ada penguatan kewenangan itu, ada
penyadapan tanpa prosedur perizinan yang
jelas, ada pengawasan dan pembinaan ee
apa ee lembaga lain yang itu di
monopoli. Lalu kemudian ada penindakan
pemblokiran pemutusan perlambatan akses
internet, ada penggalangan intelijen,
ada perpanjangan penahanan menjadi 40
hari. Padahal sebelumnya hanya sekitar
20 hari. Ada penggeledahan tanpa izin
pengadilan pada keadaan mendesak. Tentu
konsep mendesak ini bisa perdebatan dan
sangat multitafsir. Penyidik juga berhak
untuk menentukan kuasa hukum bagi
tersangka atau terdakwa. Ini biasanya
bisa menjadi ajang kongkalikong.
Dan inilah secara sederhana kalau kita
lihat cara rezim Prabowo Gibran untuk
memperkuat otot politik melalui
penguatan di undang-undang ee rancangan
undang-undang Polri.
penguatan itu tidak hanya di dalam
rancangan undang-undang Polri. Kalau
kita lihat hal yang sama, itu juga
terjadi di rancangan Undang-Undang
KUHAP.
Ada banyak sekali catatan di situ.
Misalnya saja ada kewenangan polisi
ditambah untuk melakukan penyidikan
tanpa pemberitahuan ke penuntut umum.
Ada juga pemeriksaan dapat direkam
dengan kamera pengawas. Dapat direkam
ini seperti seakan-akan tidak menjadi
kewajiban ya sema menjadi pilihan. Juga
ada kewenangan untuk menangkap orang
dengan dali menghambat proses
pemeriksaan dan informasi tidak sesuai
fakta. Coba dibayangkan ini sangat
diskresional.
Masih di dalam rancangan undang-undang
yang sama, rancangan undang-undang KOHP.
Ada juga soal perpanjangan penahan
penyidikan hingga 40 hari, penggeledahan
tanpa izin pengadilan dalam keadaan
mendesak, penyidikan, berhak menentukan
kuasa hukum bagi tersangka atau terdakwa
dan tentu saja ini adalah cara rezim
Prabowo Gibran untuk memperkuat otot
politik melalui dukungan yang kuat di
kepolisian Republik Indonesia.
[Musik]
[Tepuk tangan]
Sekarang tibalah saatnya
kami meminta persetujuan fraksi-fraksi
terhadap Rancangan Undang-Undang tentang
Perubahan atas Undang-Undang Nomor 34
Tahun 2004 tentang Tentara Nasional
Indonesia. Apakah dapat disetujui untuk
disahkan menjadi undang-undang?
Terima kasih.
Potongan video ini sebenarnya
menggambarkan cara ugal-ugalan di balik
pengesahan rancangan Undang-Undang TNI
menjadi Undang-Undang TNI.
Kenapa ugal-ugalan dan kenapa menjadi
seperti cepat-cepatan? Barangkali ini
bisa tergambar dari dinamika bagaimana
rancangan Undang-Undang TNI itu
menggunakan kekuatan bersenjata,
menggunakan kekuatan sangat luar biasa
untuk menutup
peluang partisipasi publik sehingga
seakan-akan gedung DPR dipagari dan
dibatasi dari kemungkinan mendapatkan
aspirasi publik maupun partisipasi
publik.
Kita bisa bayangkan ya di gedung milik
rakyat namun tidak ada kesempatan yang
diberikan kepada publik untuk memberikan
partisipasi yang bermakna.
Tidak hanya berkaitan soal rancangan
undang-undang prosesnya saja. Bukan
hanya sekedar formilnya. Kalau kita
periksa dengan baik, substansinya juga
memberikan perluasan kewenangan bagi TNI
sangat banyak. Misalnya saja aturan ini
memberikan
kewenangan penuh kepada Presiden untuk
memerintahkan operasi militer di luar
perang tanpa persetujuan parlemen untuk
mengatasi separatisme. Tentu ada
perdebatan di sini karena bukan sekedar
bagaimana konteks separatisme, tetapi
juga bicara soal persetujuan parlemen
yang biasanya harus dilakukan.
belum lagi menambah ee posisi sipil yang
bisa diduduki dari dulunya hanya 10
menjadi 14 posisi. Lalu ada penambahan
kewenangan yang kelihatannya mengurus
hal di luar ee urusan militer yaitu soal
narkoba maupun urusan cyber.
Kita tidak hanya sekedar bicara dari
soalan em kewenangan saja. Gambar yang
Anda lihat ini sebenarnya menggambarkan
betapa
anggaran pertahanan itu mengalami
peningkatan yang sangat signifikan dan
terus-menerus.
Dan bisa dibayangkan ini dilakukan
bahkan di tahun ketika Prabowo dan
Gibran jualan soal efisiensi anggaran.
Peningkatan anggaran tahun 2005,
2025 sampai 2026 kalau Anda bayangkan
itu mencapai hingga 36,7%.
Selain itu, Prabowo juga menambah
kekuatan militer
organik.
Dengan mengucap bismillahirrahmanirrahim
pada pagi hari ini, hari Minggu tanggal
10 Agustus tahun 2025,
saya Prabowo Subianto,
Presiden Republik Indonesia
dengan ini meresmikan
en Komando Daerah Militer,
14 Komando Daerah Angkatan Laut.
Tiga, komando daerah angkatan udara
satu komando operasi udara 6 grup
komando pasukan khusus
20 brigade
teritorial pembangunan,
satu brigade infanteri marinir
satu resimen kors pasukan gerak cepat
100 batalion teritori Tutorial
pembangunan lima, batalyon infantri
marinir
lima, batalyon komando kors pasukan
gerak cepat.
[Musik]
Tidak hanya tentara organik, Prabowo
juga melanjutkan rencananya. Ini harus
dijelaskan secara lebih detail ya.
Pembentukan komponen cadangan yang
merupakan bagian dari tentara
nonorganik. Pada tahun 2024 Kemenhan
sudah mendapatkan 9.700-an
anggota komponen cadangan dari target
25.000 orang.
jumlah ini akan terus bertambah ya
seiring dengan ee tahun berjalan dan
mudah membayangkan ditambah dengan cara
pandang melihat urusan pertahanan yang
seakan-akan dilebarkan makna pertahanan
tidak hanya kaitan dengan militer tapi
juga berkaitan dengan hal-hal yang
berfungsi sosial dan inilah akibatnya
TNI
setiap
juga dipaksa untuk membuat urusan
berkaitan dengan urusan panganj
dan kami anggap bahwa ini bukan daerah
operasi Operasi militer.
Terus kenapa harus datangkan militer
banyak-banyak
daerah kami?
Setelah pasukannya sudah
sudah dirop,
keduanya alat berat muncul
dengan alasan bahwa kami mehkan
jalan.
dia masuk langsung digusur tanpa ada
sosialisasi.
Setiap beko itu itu ada aparat dikawal
terus.
tidak hanya berkaitan soal ee urusan
pangan ya, urusan yang lainnya berkaitan
juga dengan urusan sosial ee selain
pertahanan itu dilihat dari cakupan TNI
yang juga diperluas ke hal seperti
mengurusi penyerapan gabah,
mengurus penyelenggaraan dapur untuk
makan bergizi gratis MBG
termasuk mengurus dapur MBG G seperti
yang kita lihat di Provinsi Papua. Nah,
lebih lanjut kalau kita analisis bagian
dari upaya menguatkan otot otot ee
politik melalui dukungan ke ee tentara
ke TNI ini kita lihat dari penempatan
perwira aktif di pos jabatan sipil di
luar dari yang diperbolehkan.
Undang-undang sudah membolehkan 14.
Bahkan ada seperti di penyelenggaraan
haji, Perum Bulok, bahkan di Kementerian
Pertanian.
Ini juga sama dengan kepolisian
sebenarnya jelas melanggar karena
Undang-Undang TNI sudah mengatur tentang
bagaimana anggota TNI aktif pada jabatan
sipil, mana wilayah yang diperbolehkan
ya dan kemudian apa yang harus dilakukan
ketika itu di luar jabatan yang
diperbolehkan.
Namun untuk jabatan sipil yang diatur
dalam undang-undang peraturannya
sebenarnya sudah jelas ya. Sekali lagi
harus diingatkan harus mundur atau
pensiun dari dinas aktif.
Saya ingin melanjutkan dengan
kita harus menghitung dengan baik ya
kebijakan-kebijakan ini apakah dikaitkan
dengan kebutuhan di internal TNI atau
tidak. Sebab kalau kita lihat dari data
ini sebenarnya sudah ada kelebihan
jumlah personil baik di jumlah jenderal
maupun di jumlah kolonel. Kalau kita
lihat ada kelebihan jumlah jenderal
sebanyak 179 orang karena kebutuhan
hanya 1114
jumlah rilnya adalah 1293.
Begitu juga untuk jabatan kolonel dari
kebutuhan 5.423,
jumlah ril saat ini itu adalah 5.661,
ada kelebihan 238.
Coba bayangkan analisis ini kami
dapatkan dari tulisan yang dimuat di
dalam sebuah jurnal edukasi humaniora
dan sains social sains di tahun 2024.
bahkan ditulis dari orang internal
tentara sendiri.
Bagian yang tidak bisa dilupakan adalah
adanya tim mawar. Ya, tim mawar sekedar
mengingatkan Anda, tim mawar itu adalah
tim yang dikaitkan dan sudah terbukti
terlibat dalam penculikan aktivis di
tahun 98.
Ada serangkaian nama, ada banyak nama,
tetapi para anggota tim mawar ini tetap
mendapatkan posisi di sekitar Prabowo.
Dan kita tahu memang ada relasi kuat
antara Prabowo dan Tim Mawar. Misalnya
ada Jaka Budi Utama jadi Dirjen Bea
Cukai, ada Nugroho Sulistio jadi Kepala
Badan Cber dan Sandi Negara, ada Dadang
Hendra Yuda jadi deputi pemantauan dan
pengawasan Badan Gizi Nasional. Jangan
lupa juga ada nama Selvianus Selvanus
yang menjabat sebagai Gubernur Sulawesi
Utara.
Sebenarnya untuk berkaitan dengan ini,
rancangan Undang-Undang TNI yang dibuat
secara serampangan hingga saat ini sudah
ada begitu banyak putusan. Sayangnya
Mahkamah Konstitusi masih belum mengawal
dengan baik rancangan undang-undang ini
karena kemudian terjadi penolakan di
begitu banyak permohonan dari 14
permohonan 10 di antaranya tidak
diterima, tiga ditarik oleh pemohon dan
satu ditolak karena permohonan hukumnya
dianggap tidak beralasan.
Dari sini ya kita bisa lihat sebenarnya
bagaimana
Prabowo
ingin meng-entertain
polisi maupun militer. Sebab pada saat
yang sama dia membayangkan ada semacam
kekuatan otot politik yang bisa dia
dapatkan dari penguatan kedua-duanya.
Dan salah satunya bisa kita lihat dari
cara dia melihat
pucuk pimpinan Polri yaitu Kapolri dan
pucuk pimpinan TNI yaitu Panglima TNI.
Yang terhormat Kepala Kepolisian
Republik Indonesia Jenderal Polisi
Liskio Sigit Prabowo.
[Musik]
Memang Prabowo ini
namanya
sak keranjang itu
Panglima TNI Jenderal TNI Agus Subianto.
Jadi ada Kapolri namanya Prabowo,
panglima TNI namanya Subyanto.
Presid Presidennya Prabowo Subianto.
Wah, ini alamat enggak diganti-ganti nih
Kapolri.
Itu yang pertama kami menjelaskan soal
otot. Kita masuk yang kedua. yaitu otak.
Sekali lagi saya jelaskan tadi ya,
bagian dari rangkaian insecure itu
kemudian dibangun
ingin diselesaikan dengan cara mengakali
otak hukum, membangun ee hukum, lalu
kemudian menggunakan koalisi yang besar
untuk menyokong itu. ini bisa kita lihat
sebenarnya bahkan sebelum dilantik jadi
presiden,
Presiden Prabowo itu sudah mengirimkan
signal bahwa dia akan membangun koalisi
gemuk. Bahkan ada semacam alergi
berlebihan terhadap adanya oposisi.
Jadi, Saudara-saudara,
kita harus kerja sama, kita harus
collaborate.
Jangan kita mau ikut-ikut
budaya lain. Budaya Barat atau budaya
mana itu mungkin suka apa ya,
oposisi-oposisi gontok-gontokan.
Oposisi enggak mau kerja sama.
Itu mungkin budaya mereka. Budaya kita
sudahlah ya kan
ramai-ramai
bersaing. Tidak mungkin kita tidak
bersaing. Hidup ini persaingan.
Kita kemudian tahu bahwa ada keinginan
Prabowo untuk merangkul sebanyak mungkin
parpol untuk masuk ke koalisinya. Ini
adalah bagian dari penguatan otot itu
yang di yang dibarengi dengan penguatan
pengkondisian otak yang dapat kita
terjemahkan dengan seperti apa yang
terjadi ini. Yaitu apa? Prabowo kemudian
menggemukkan kabinet meskipun kita bisa
lihat ini diamini oleh Presiden
sebelumnya karena melakukan perubahan
terhadap undang-undang Kementerian
Negara yang memberikan kesempatan bagi
Presiden untuk melantik atau memilih
jabatan menteri dan wakil menteri secara
unlimited. Kalau kita lihat Jokowi
menandatangani undang-undang yang
memberikan atau menghapus batasan jumlah
Kementerian Negara tersebut di dalam
Undang-Undang 61 Tahun 2024.
Di sini Anda bisa bandingkan ya. Itu
yang mengakibatkan pasca ee reformasi
ada peningkatan jumlah menteri yang
sangat luar biasa khususnya di zaman ee
Prabowo Subianto. Kalau di Habibi hanya
berkisar 37-an. Semuanya berkisar 30-an.
Tapi khusus di Prabowo Subianto, ia
kemudian
apa membangunnya hingga 49.
Ketiadaan aturan pembatasan dalam
undang-undang. Seperti yang saya
sampaikan sebelumnya, itulah yang
memungkinkan Prabowo Gibran menjadi
pemilik menteri terbanyak sejak
reformasi.
Saudara-saudara sekalian,
jumlah anggota kabinet kita
sebanyak 48 menteri.
Juga ada badan-badan yang sangat
strategis.
ini memang lebih banyak dari
pemerintah-pemerintah sebelumnya.
Jumlah ini
ee saya sadari memang
bisa dianggap tergolong besar,
tapi memang bangsa kita bangsa yang
besar.
Kita tidak dapat pungkiri bahwa kita
negara keempat terbesar di dunia dari
jumlah penduduk.
dari luas wilayah kita luasnya sama
dengan Eropa, Barat.
Mari kita periksa statement Pak Presiden
yang mengatakan bahwa bangsa besar itu
membutuhkan jumlah kabinet yang banyak.
Kami mengkategorisasi sekitar tiga
pendekatan. Pertama, kalau kita lihat
dari konteks negara kesatuan,
Indonesia tetap menjadi yang terbanyak.
Indonesia jauh di atas Ghana, Kongo,
Kamerun, Pantai Gading, maupun Korea
Utara. Kalau kita menggunakan
perbandingan yang lainnya ya menggunakan
konteks negara dengan sistem federal,
tetap saja Indonesia menjadi yang
terbanyak. Dia atas Bosnia, Kanada,
Sudan Selatan, Malaysia, dan UEA. Dan
yang paling menarik ini langsung
berkaitan dengan statement Pak Presiden,
yaitu jumlah kementerian terbanyak
dibandingkan dengan angka jumlah
penduduk. Kita melebihi India, China,
Amerika Serikat, Pakistan. Kita memiliki
53 kementerian yang itu
jauh di atas negara-negara yang besar.
49 apa,
Pak?
Jumlah kementerian kita 53.
53 untuk menteri dan jabatan setingkat
menteri.
Oh, sama badan-badan ya.
I
oke.
Nah, kita lihat di hal yang sama terjadi
di jumlah wakil menteri
ya. Kalau kita baca undang-undang,
sebenarnya wakil menteri itu untuk
tujuan khusus.
Hanya untuk tujuan khusus. Maka
pemerintah dapat, presiden dapat
menunjuk wakil menteri. Ini yang
mengakibatkan kita sering bertanya apa
tujuan khusus yang sedang dibangun oleh
Presiden Prabowo. Karena kalau kita
bandingkan dari masa SBY, Jokowi,
Jokowi JK pertama, Jokowi Mar'ruf yang
kedua dan Prabowo.
Bahkan ketiga presiden ini kalau
dijumlahkan belum capai, belum dapat
mengejar jumlah wamen di zaman Prabowo
dan Gibrat. 57 wakil menteri mudah untuk
menciumnya bahwa ini adalah bagian dari
keinginan untuk bagi-bagi kue kekuasaan
untuk memperkuat
otak hukum tersebut.
Dan saya katakan di sini kita berhasil
karena kita didukung
oleh presiden ketujuh.
Tepuk tangannya kurang semangat.
Semangat lagi.
Hidup Jokowi.
[Tepuk tangan]
Terima kasih.
Terima kasih. Terima kasih.
Terima kasih Pak Jokowi.
Bokowi.
Terima kasih.
Terima kasih. Terima kasih.
Terima kasih Pak Jokowi.
Terima kasih.
Apa
yang Anda saksikan sebenarnya seperti
yang saya sampaikan tadi, setelah
kemudian membagi memperbesar kue
kekuasaan untuk dibagi, Presiden Prabowo
juga menjaga
ya relasi dengan Presiden sebelumnya dan
itu adalah bagian ada juga bagian Gibran
di situ secara sangat mesra. Ini kita
bisa lihat dari gejala kunjung
mengunjungi yang terjadi antara Presiden
Prabowo dan mantan Presiden Joko Widodo.
Pak,
selamat sore. Terima kasih
Presiden. Iya.
Baru sempat mampir, Pak. Baru keliling,
Pak.
saya
sekali lagi mudah untuk membahasakan
rasa insecure lah yang membuat ada
semacam ketakutan untuk ditinggalkan
oleh ee presiden yang sebelumnya dan di
situ juga ada anaknya yang menjabat
sebagai wakil presiden. Dan ini juga
kita bisa kaitkan berkaitan barangkali
secara sederhana melihat pola relasi
antara Prabowo dan Jokowi itu memang ada
semacam simbiose mutualisme ya kalau
kita lihat. Karena sesaat sebelum
menjadi presiden sebenarnya Prabowo
diberikan
jenderal bintang empat yang kita tahu
persis itu pasti diimpikan oleh Prabowo
yang dipaksa berhenti di tahun 98 karena
proses berkaitan dengan penculikan
aktivis
bagian dari menjaga relasi mesranya nya
dengan Jokowi itu yang membuat tidak
lama setelah Prabowo dilantik kita
menenggarai ada relasi yang tidak
sederhana ketika ada pentersangkaan Tom
Lembong oleh kejaksaan atas kasus gula
impor gula Tom diketahui itu merupakan
tim sukses Anis Baswedan yang menjadi
rival Prabowo sekaligus barangkali bekas
dari tim suksesnya ee Jokowi di masa
lalu. Lalu kemudian pada saat yang sama
ya itu terjadi juga di Hristianto.
Dalam bahasa kita sebenarnya ada semacam
weaponizing law menggunakan hukum untuk
menjatuhkan atau kemudian melakukan
politik balas dendam terhadap
rival-rival politik. Dalam kaitan ini
tentu saja adalah berkaitan dengan
kepentingan mantan presiden yang lama.
Ini adalah bagaimana kemudian PDIP
melakukan ee tanggapan terhadap
penetapan tersangka yang terjadi pada
Hasto Kristianto. PDI secara resmi itu
memberikan instruksi harian ya ketua
umumnya untuk semua kader dari ee PDIP
dilarang ya dengan cara menunda
perjalanan untuk menghadiri retreat
kepala daerah yang dilakukan oleh
Presiden Prabowo sesaat setelah
ee Pilkada dan terpilihnya ee
kepala-kepala daerah.
Kita semua paham ya bagian dari
penguatan politik ini Prabowo harus
mencari kesetimbangan dan itu sebabnya
peta ini pun berubah dengan adanya
pemberian amnesti dan abolisi dalam
kasus Tom Lembong dan Hasto Kristianto.
Terkhusus nama terakhir ini Hasto
Kristianto langsungkan terima kasih
terhadap Prabowo. Bahkan kalau dikaitkan
dengan em
ketua PDIP yaitu ee Megawati inilah yang
kemudian mengubah konstelasi dan
akhirnya Megawati kemudian mengumumkan
dukungan terhadap Presiden Prabowo
setelah bertemu secara langsung.
meskipun ya dukungannya tidak berada
dalam barisan koalisi Prabowo, tapi
jelas PDIP mengatakan mendukung Prabowo.
Kalau mau dijelaskan secara sederhana,
sebenarnya pemberian amnesti dan abolisi
ini juga berbau anyir ya. Jelas
sebenarnya kalau kita lihat sangat tidak
pernah dilakukan pemberian amnesti dan
abolisi yang biasanya dikaitkan dengan
kasus politik dan menjaga yang namanya
ee apa menjaga yang namanya kondisi
sosial kemasyarakatan termasuk dikaitkan
dengan politik sosial politik itu
kemudian digunakan untuk kasus
korupsi.
Ini barangkali adalah kejadian terakhir
ya yang paling terkini yaitu ketika
Pasca prahara Agustus ada ya semacam
tuduhan atau ada semacam ee kabar yang
beredar bahwa ada keterlibatan dari
merah maupun orang-orang merah dan itu
yang mengakibatkan
dipecatnya dua pejabat PDIP.
dan mereka kena resffel.
Bagian dari menguatkan
otak ini ya, Presiden juga harus membawa
pasukan pendukungnya di TKN itu di dalam
ee proses ee negara ya. Karenanya
Prabowo juga melakukan membagi-bagi
jabatan pemenangan ini melalui ya
sesuatu yang lebih bersifat eh ekonomi
yaitu apa? Tim kampanye nasional Prabowo
Gibran hampir semuanya kemudian
dikonversi menjadi pemegang jabatan di
perusahaan BUMN sebagai komisaris.
tidak berhenti di TKN. Pada saat yang
sama dilakukan juga terhadap
partai-partai pendukung ya, orang-orang
partai yang sebagian besar adalah
koalisi besar Pak Prabowo.
Dan entah kebetulan atau tidak
Gerindra sebagai partai penyokong nomor
satu bagi Presiden Prabowo itu
mendapatkan sampai 48,6%.
[Musik]
jabatan ya komisaris
di BMNBMN
sedangkan sisanya dinikmati oleh
partai-partai lain secara ee beragam.
Masih berkaitan dengan itu sebagai
kue-kue kekuasaan yang tadi dibagi bukan
hanya kepada menteri tapi juga kepada
wakil menteri khususnya mungkin
barangkali karena wakil menteri dianggap
tidak punya konstelasi yang jelas secara
ee penggajian. Itu sebabnya Prabowo
memilih untuk mengkonversinya menjadi
jabatan komisaris di berbagai perusahaan
BUMN. Setidaknya ada 30 dari 57 wakil
menteri atau tentu saja lebih dari
setengahnya itu mendapatkan jabatan
komisaris di berbagai perusahaan BUMN.
[Musik]
Perkenalkan saya Bima Yudistira di
negara. Saya saat ini menjadi direktur
dari lembaga riset Celios Center of
Economic and Law Studies yang bergerak
di bidang ekonomi dan kebijakan publik.
Riwayat pendidikan saya S1 di Fakultas
Ekonomi dan Bisnis Universitas Gadjah
Mada. Kemudian menempuh S2 di University
of Bradford dengan training di Tulus
Business School di Prancis. Dan salah
satu keahlian adalah di bidang
makroekonomi,
keuangan, dan juga terkait dengan energi
terbarukan.
[Musik]
Kita masuk ke O yang ketiga. O yang
ketiga ini sebenarnya adalah ongkos ya.
Ongkos itu berkaitan dengan bagaimana
otak dan bagaimana otot yang tadi sudah
saya jelaskan itu membutuhkan
pembiayaan.
Dan ongkos ini berkaitan dengan ekonomi.
Iya. Kita enggak ahli. Abang ahli
enggak?
Saya tentu tidak merasa ahli untuk itu,
Beb.
Saya juga enggak,
Mas Feri. Nah, tapi saya punya teman
saya akan panggilkan secara usia
barangkali junior, tapi secara
pengetahuan sangat luar biasa karena
sering melakukan ee
riset-riset berkaitan dengan ekonomi.
Saya panggilkan Mas Bima Judistira. Wah,
Bima.
Halo, Bang.
Apa kabar, Mas?
Mantap.
Thank you, thank you, thank you sudah
datangnya
bawain dong, Fer.
Oh, saya bawain
gestar. Saya bawa.
Sip. Mantap.
Makasih. Silakan, Mas Wima.
Tadi Bang Zainal sudah membahas terkait
dengan otot dan juga otak politik. Tapi
tentu ini membutuhkan konsolidasi yang
cukup besar sehingga kita harus
menyentuh terkait dengan ongkos politik
itu. Nah, kalau kita lihat ongkos
politik itu akan kita bagi menjadi
empat. Yang pertama adalah level
grassroot. Yang kedua adalah level
jejaring politik. Ini dengan makan
bergizi gratis. Tapi juga ada danantara.
Tadi yang sempat dibahas oleh Bang
Zainal
soal elit ekonomi.
Banyak hebohnya kan Danantara
dan cukup kontroversial. Tapi juga di
level regional ini ada hubungan
Indonesia dengan China baik secara
bilateral maupun di forum seperti
bricks. Nah, pertama kita akan bahas
dulu terkait dengan Koperasi Desa Merah
Putih. Jadi, Koperasi Desa Merah Putih
ini awalnya dia ingin mendorong
perekonomian yang sifatnya gotongroyong
yang di bawah ini bisa menghidupi dengan
cara berkoperasi.
Dan ini bukan hal yang aneh pada
awalnya, tetapi
koperasi Desa Merah Putih kalau kita
lihat ada 83.700
jumlah desa kelurahan se-Indonesia.
Hanya dalam waktu yang singkat itu sudah
ada 81.500
desa yang sudah memiliki koperas waktu
kurang dari 1 tahun.
Kurang dari 1 tahun. Ini sangat cepat.
Dan ini artinya apa? Ada kontradiksi di
mana koperasi Desa Merah Putih sifatnya
adalah top down. Berbeda dengan konsep
koperasi yang sifatnya adalah swakelola
dan juga sukarela, bottom up
ya. Dan ini menjadi kesan bahwa
pembentukan koperasi ini ini juga
terkait dengan ongkos politik tadi.
He.
Nah, kami juga punya data nih dari studi
yang dilakukan oleh Selios itu
memperliamu ya Selios ya.
Salah satu pendiri ini kalau kita lihat
hasil dari studi
apa saja yang menarik? Salah satunya ini
membuat otonomi desa karena dana desanya
itu menjadi
berkonflik dengan adanya koperasi desa
Merah Putih.
Apalagi banyak desa yang sudah punya
badan usaha milik desa
sehingga ada pembagian sumber daya
kepada koperasi Desa Merah Putih. Tapi
bukan cuman itu, koperasi Desa Merah
Putih ini juga menjadi kanibal terhadap
UMKM yang sudah ada di desa-desa. Jadi
sudah ada yang menjadi pengecer LPG,
sudah ada yang menjadi pengecer pupuk.
Tapi dengan koperasi Desa Merah Putih
akhirnya terjadi perebutan sama-sama
menjual komoditas yang hampir sama di
desa-desa.
Dan koperasi merah putih itu diturunkan
dari atas gitu untuk
dan ini sangat top down. He.
Tapi kalau kita lihat, kita punya
pengalaman sebelumnya terkait dengan
bagaimana kebijakan di level desa tadi
itu sangat berpengaruh terhadap praktik
korupsi.
I
karena kalau dilihat dari data ini, 10
sektor tindak pidana korupsi itu tahun
2022 paling besar adalah dari korupsi
APBD desa. Bahkan lebih tinggi daripada
korupsi.
Ini setelah dana desa digelontorkan luar
biasa besar kan? setelah dana desa
digelontorkan sangat besar. Bahkan kalau
kita lihat selain ee COPDES merah putih
ini juga bisa menjadi daya tawar, tapi
di sisi yang lain ada program di level
grassroot yang disebut sebagai makan
bergizi gratis.
Hm.
Pada awalnya makan bergizi gratis ini
ditujukan untuk mengurangi stunting.
Berarti targetnya adalah balita di bawah
1000 hari pertama. He.
Kemudian ibu-ibu.
Nah, yang menarik ketika makan bergizi
gratis menjadi program prioritas,
anggarannya enggak main-main.
Anggarannya R1 triliun 2025 dan itu juga
menimbulkan beberapa hal yang enggak
siap di lapangan. Mulai dari keracunan,
mulai dari nilai gizi yang tidak sesuai
dan anggarannya itu akan dinaikkan lagi
menjadi 335 triliun pada tahun 2026.
Nah, anggaran MBG yang besar ini itu
kalau kita lihat alur tata kelolanya di
sini kelihatan sekali nih yang
mengerjakan adalah Badan Gizi Nasional.
Tapi di sini kalau dilihat Bang Zainal
ini Kementerian Pertahanan
ya tadi karena ada ya apa perluasan
makna pertahanan itu kan
perluasan makna pertahanan. Padahal
kalau sasarannya adalah bersiswa di
tingkat SD sampai dengan SMA, ibu hamil
balita, bukankah yang lebih cocok untuk
mengerjakan makan bergizi gratis
seharusnya adalah Kementerian Pendidikan
ataupun Kementerian Kesehatan.
Tapi kalau ini kan artinya organisasi
dan tata kelola ini kan harusnya kita
punya. Sampai sekarang emang Perpresnya
sudah ada.
Nah, sampai sekarang soal tata kelola
itu Perpresnya belum ada juga. Artinya
kebijakan MBG ini diambil tanpa tata
kelola yang memadai.
Tanpa tata kelola yang memadai.
Nah, selain itu kita juga melihat sudah
bahas COPDES makan bergizi gratis.
Tetapi ada juga yang menarik nih. Kita
juga punya temuan soal jaringan ccle
politik terkait dengan markan bergizi
gratis ini. Tetapi kita akan simpan itu
di akhir film ini. Nah, penting itu ya?
penting itu.
Jika tadi berkaitan nih dengan circle
politik maupun di level grass root, tapi
yang perlu dilihat adalah ongkos politik
dari sisi elit. Salah satunya adalah
dengan diresmikannya Danantara. Jadi
Danantara ini bukan hal yang baru. Di
banyak negara sebenarnya punya model
pengelola dana abadi seperti Danantara.
Ada
Temasek dari Singapura, Khazanah,
Malaysia, kemudian Norwegia. salah satu
yang paling tua
untuk dana abadi ini. Tetapi yang
menarik kalau dilihat dari susunan
lembaga pengelola dana investasi
danantara ini muncul beberapa wajah yang
sepertinya punya kedekatan pada ccle
elit dari Prabowo Gibran, Mas Zainal.
Contohnya misalnya ada Joko Widodo yang
anaknya sebenarnya adalah Wapres. dia
ditempatkan sebagai dewan penasehat,
tapi juga ada Roslan Roslani, kemudian
Pandu Syahrir, ada Erik Tohir yang ini
juga terlibat di dalam Pemilu 2024
kemarin. Nah, di sinilah
tim sukses berarti
sebagian besar adalah tim sukses
dan kalau dilihat sebenarnya
cara Danantara untuk mendanai
proyek-proyek strategis tadi ini juga
menarik perhatian dari publik karena
baru saja dia mengeluarkan apa yang
disebut sebagai Patriot Bond.
Apa sih itu Pot?
Nah, saya mau ngejelasin sambil
coret-coret sebentar. I
ini orang hukum tata tata negara bilang
patriot bond itu dekat dengan James Bond
Cang.
Iya iya iya betul.
Jadi Patriot Bond itu bisa dijelaskan
secara sederhana nih, Bang. Jadi Patriot
Bond ini kenapa dia disebut sebagai
patriotik? Itu karena
menawarkan bunga sebesar 2%. Sementara
kalau para pengusaha ini beli dari SBN
atau surat utang pemerintah, dia
dikenakan bunga atau mendapatkan bunga
6,2%.
Yang artinya apa? Yang artinya
konglomerat sebenarnya pembeli dari
Patriot Bond ini itu kehilangan potensi
bunga 4,2% per tahunnya.
Oh, itu yang membuat disebut patriotik
gitu.
Patriotik. Tapi tentunya ini bukan
biaya yang kemudian hilang begitu saja.
He.
Tapi para konglomerat ini atau pengusaha
yang membeli Patriot Bond, dia
sebenarnya juga memiliki tujuan yang
pertama agar dianggap sebagai loyalis
mendukung program-program dari Prabowo.
tapi juga ada yang kemudian melihat
bahwa beberapa pelaku usaha itu
sebelumnya dari sisi perizinan, ada juga
kriminalisasi sehingga mereka melihat
ini sebagai bentuk dari asuransi politik
proteksi gitu ya.
E iya agar bisnisnya ke depan paling
tidak sepanjang 4 tahun ke depan itu
tidak diganggu oleh pemerintah atau
kekuasaan. Artinya kalau dalam model
begini belum tentu betul-betul patriotik
kerelaan. Bisa jadi juga karena injak
kaki gitu.
Nah, itu dia untuk menjawab tadi
pertanyaan siapa sih sebenarnya yang
membeli Patriot Bond tadi? Maka kita
akan lihat di dalam list yang beredar
terkait mereka yang membeli dari Patriot
Bond ini. Siapa saja?
Salah satunya adalah. Nah, nama-nama ini
nih. Jadi, triliun itu yang dimaksud
adalah dia memesan Patriot Bond.
Misalnya Antoni Salim, dia memesan Rp3
triliun untuk membeli Patriot Bond.
Kemudian ada Prayogo Pangestu. Ini grup
yang cukup familiar,
nama-nama terkenal. Ada Sinarmas juga.
Ini kalau kita lihat ada dua indikasi.
Indikasi yang pertama memang ini adalah
konglomerat yang berada di dalam
lingkaran dulu Jokowi kemudian sekarang
ke Pak Prabowo. Tapi juga kalau dilihat
sebagian besar ini adalah para
konglomerat yang mendukung
program-program strategis. Apakah dia
hilirisasi
nikel misalnya hilirisasi batu bara atau
gasifikasi batu bara.
Oke.
Bisa juga di sektor sawit sampai
perumahan karena ada beberapa perumahan
di sini. Nah, sayangnya saya enggak
ngelihat nama Bang Zainal nih dalam list
ini. Iya,
karena ya mereka itu punya program juga
di PSN. Saya enggak punya program di
PSN.
Nah, itu dia berarti Bang Zainal harus
mendukung PSN.
Iya.
Artinya kalau
ini bisa enggak angkanya 0,00 sekian
gitu kecil sekali di sini.
Bisa saja. Bisa saja ya. Tapi yang
menarik, Bang Zainal, dari Rp50 triliun
rencana untuk menarik dana Patriot Bond
itu ternyata over subscribe alias laku
keras di pasar sehingga didapat Rp51,7
triliun. Tapi sebelum itu, kenapa ada
Patriot bond? Sebelumnya kita bisa lihat
Pak Prabowo juga sempat mengundang 8
konglomerat ke istana. Nah, ini adalah
wajah-wajah konglomerat yang hadir di
istana berbincang langsung dengan
Presiden dan yang menarik setelah itu
mengumumkan adanya Patriot Bondanantara
ini. Dari beberapa nama yang hadir tadi
dan nama-nama yang cukup familiar itu
kalau kita perhatikan ada kurang lebih
11 nama dan 11 nama ini misalnya Antoni
Salim, ada Praugo Pangestu, ada Frankie
Wijaya, Adi, ada Garibaldi Thhir atau
Boy Tohir,
Tohir,
kemudian ada Tommy Winata. Jadi sebagian
besar memang terkait dengan oligarki di
sektor ekstraktif, tapi juga ada di
sektor perumahan. He.
Jadi, apakah bergabung dengan Prabowo
atau sebagian merasa bahwa harus
diingatkan agar dia loyal terhadap
pemerintahan Prabowo. He.
Nah, selain itu tidak hanya berhenti di
level elit, tapi juga di level
internasional,
di level circle internasional. Pak
Prabowo ini coba melihat bahwa hubungan
dari Danantara kemudian uang dari hasil
Patriot Bond itu sebagian juga masuk
pada proyek-proyek yang ada kaitannya.
Contohnya misalnya ini kalau kita lihat
sangat familiar ada Morowali dengan 38,4
triliun. He
industri pelat baja di tahan karat ini.
He
atau stainless steel ini juga terkait
sebenarnya dengan investasi asal China
atau Tiongkok.
Oh, itu yang tadi maksudnya
internasional gitu ya.
Kemudian ada lagi yang menarik ini
adalah di industri batu bara. Jadi
gasifikasi batu bara di Muara Enim
tujuannya untuk menggantikan LPG 3 kg.
Jadi kita enggak impor LPG digantikan
gasifikasi batu bara. Tapi ini adalah
proyek yang sebenarnya enggak terlalu
laris, enggak terlalu laku sehingga
dioper kepada Danantara.
Kalau kita perhatikan
beberapa proyek-proyek yang didanai atau
akan didanai oleh Danantara itu tadi
kita sebutkan ada hubungannya dengan
kedekatan Indonesia dengan China. He.
China itu punya program yang namanya
jalur sutra bararu. Ini kalau kita lihat
ya jalur sutra baru itu penjelasan
sederhananya adalah China ingin
membangun kekuatan ekonomi terutama di
negara-negara berkembang
sehingga dia bisa mengekstraksi sumber
daya alamnya. ditarik,
ditarik, diolah kemudian dilempar lagi
menjadi barang jadi untuk dibeli. Jadi
beberapa dianggap hanya sebagai pasar
yang sangat besar bagi produk-produk
asal Tiongkok. Nah, ini adalah sebagai
bentuk ya sebagai bentuk membagikan
ongkos-ongkos politik antara kepentingan
Prabog Gibran itu dengan kepentingan
China secara global.
Dan kalau dilihat nilainya besar sekali.
Nilai ongkos politik ini
bisa tercermin dari data yang ada pada
tahun 2024.
Indonesia menduduki investasi nomor 1 di
ASEAN nilainya 61,7
miliar dolar hampir dua kali lipat
dibandingkan Vietnam. itu artinya
Prabowo coba untuk mendekatkan diri
kepada China melanjutkan apa yang sudah
dilakukan oleh Jokowi.
Tapi tidak berhenti di situ.
Dibandingkan dengan lembaga
internasional yang memberikan pendanaan
untuk pembangunan,
nilai pembangunan dari China itu
angkanya sangat besar. Contoh yang
sebelumnya sudah ada EDB. ADB ini lebih
dekat kaitannya dengan
Jepang dan Korea Selatan, ASEAN
Development Bank. IBRD ini adalah
jaringan atau grup dari World Bank, Bank
Dunia.
Heeh.
Nilainya kalau dibandingkan dengan
beltroad inisiatif itu jauh sekali di
bawah. Ini membuktikan apa? membuktikan
bahwa memang proyek-proyek ini sangat
erat kaitannya dengan ambisi Prabowo
untuk menghubungkan ongkos politik elit
dengan internasional.
Dan kalau kita lihat nih, kita lihat
dulu videonya sebenarnya bentuk proyek
beltrad inisiatif atau jalur sutra baru
itu apa saja?
Bismillah. Dengan mengucap
bismillahirrahmanirrahim
pada siang hari ini, Kamis 20 Maret
2025, saya Prabowo Subianto, Presiden
Republik Indonesia meresmikan kawasan
ekonomi khusus Industropolis Batang,
Jawa Tengah.
[Tepuk tangan]
[Musik]
Nah, selain itu juga ada Morowali. saya
sampaikan dan dengan mengucap
bismillahirrahmanirrahim,
kereta cepat Jakarta Bandung wus
saya nyatakan dioperasikan. Terima
kasih. Wasalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.
Nah, dari tiga proyek tadi ada kawasan
industri di Batang, kemudian ada smelter
nikel di
Rowali.
Rowali, tapi juga ada kereta cepat. Nah,
yang terakhir ini menarik. Jadi kereta
cepat itu adalah salah satu bentuk
investasi atau pendanaan yang bentuknya
sebenarnya lebih tepat disebut utang.
Bahkan proyek bus ini butuh 170 tahun
untuk pengembalian utangnya. Dan
sekarang yang terjadi banyak BUMN
terutama kereta api yang keuangannya
terjepit karena menanggung utang dari
wuster.
Tapi seingat saya Purbaya juga
mengumumkan bahwa enggak mau bayar kan.
Nah, itu dia
Menteri Keuangan enggak mau dibantuin.
Betul. Kenapa alasannya? Salah satunya
karena WUS ini awalnya adalah proyek di
era Jokowi yang anaknya sekarang menjadi
wakil presiden dari Prabowo itu awalnya
adalah bisnis to bisnis tapi kemudian
berubah menjadi beban pemerintah. Tentu
dalam hal ini memang enggak rasional
kalau utang wus tadi dibebankan kepada
APBN.
Dan beragam proyek tadi itu
memperlihatkan
bagaimana kedekatan Indonesia, kedekatan
Prabowo dengan Siinping dengan China ini
membuat diplomasi internasional itu
berubah. Kalau sebelumnya Bang Zainal
mungkin ingat pada era Jokowi dulu ada
Bu Menteri Susi
yang rajin mengusir kapal-kapal asing
dan dia bilang Natuna Utara gitu. Itu
betul sekali. Saat itu banyak sekali
menyebutkan laut natura Utara. Tapi
Prabowo itu cenderung lebih soft,
lebih mengakomodir kepentingan dari
China dan lebih sering membuat statement
Laut Cina Selatan. Itu ada perubahan dan
kedekatan ini. Ini juga tercermin di
forum internasional.
Jadi begitu Pak Prabowo menjadi presiden
itu Indonesia bergabung dalam forum yang
disebut sebagai bricks. Sebenarnya
sederhananya bricks ini apa?
Sederhananya ini adalah kekuatan baru
negara-negara yang disebut
selatan-selatan atau south-suth yang
tujuannya menjadi peranding dari
hegemoni kepentingan dari barat Amerika
Serikat tentunya.
He.
Tapi di sini membuktikan kalau di situ
ada China, di situ Indonesia ingin coba
mendekat.
Tetapi kalau dilihat sebenarnya meski
Prabowo mencoba untuk mendekat H
tapi dekatnya dengan China itu juga
sebenarnya dua kaki karena dia ingin
mendekat juga dengan Amerika Serikat.
Jadi tidak benar-benar sebenarnya
kepentingannya lebih ke arah anti
Amerika.
Kalau kita lihat ini bagaimana Prabowo
terlihat bahagia setelah melakukan
negosiasi tarif dengan Amerika Serikat.
He.
Karena saat itu kan kita dikenakan tarif
yang cukup tinggi. Kemudian ada
negosiasi. Tapi kita
Indonesia merasa menang kan waktu itu
kan
berasa menang. Tapi kita akan lihat
sebenarnya tanggapan dari Trump seperti
apa.
So we made with Indonesia. I spoke
really great president very popular very
strong smart and we uh made the deal. We
have full access to Indonesia
everything. As you know, Indonesia is
very strong on copper. Uh but we have
full access to everything. We will pay
no tariffs. Uh so they are giving us
access into Indonesia which we never
had. That's probably the biggest part of
the deal. And the other part is they are
going to pay 19%
and we are going to pay nothing.
I think it's a good deal for both
[Musik]
Indonesia.
Jadi, ada beberapa keyword-nya
nothing dan full access.
Ini yang membuat sebenarnya pertanyaan
kita semua. Apakah Prabowo yang coba
mendekat kemudian ke China bahkan sampai
bergabung di forum seperti Bricks itu
punya daya tawar di depan Donald Trump?
Ternyata tidak. Ya.
He.
Ternyata sebenarnya daya tawar kita
tetap dianggap rendah. Dan taktik dua
kaki tadi itu sebenarnya bisa dilihat
lebih jauh lagi bahwa ini sebenarnya
membuka ongkos politik dengan permainan
negosiasi dagang
dan bisa jadi karena rasa insecure juga.
Salah satunya karena merasa tidak
confidence. Salah satu contohnya
misalnya yang diuntungkan terkait tarif
ini adalah pebisnis di Gandum. Kenapa?
Karena Gandum ini salah satu komoditas
pada saat negosiasi dengan Amerika.
Amerika itu menghendaki 0% tarif gandum
Amerika yang masuk ke Indonesia. Dan
kita tahulah salah satu pemain besarnya
siapa.
Ada Antoni Salim di situ dan juga tidak
hanya soal gandum, tapi juga ada pemain
baru yang mungkin muncul itu di sektor
migas. Kenapa migas? Karena
kesepakatannya juga terkait dengan kita
mengimpor lebih banyak LPG dan BBM,
minyak mentah dari Amerika Serikat.
Seperti kita tahu Bang Zainal bahwa
ongkos ekonomi ini atau ongkos politik
ini sangat rentan mafia migas masuk di
situ. Kenapa? Karena biasanya memang
sektor BBM ini
menjadi sektor yang paling bas
seperti yang sudah selama ini ya
seperti yang sudah terjadi
dan pemainnya hanya diganti.
Begitu Bang Zainal terkait dengan ongkos
politik. Saya kembalikan lagi ke Bang
Zainal.
Mas Bima.
Kasih Mas Bima.
Mas Zainal. Jadi kalau misalnya di
apa dibaca sebagai satu kesatuan, ongkos
itu mulai dari level grassroot, terus di
tengah-tengahnya elit
juga jadi cara untuk dapat ongkos sampai
level internasional itu ya.
Internasional itu bagian dari
mengakumulasi
ee kapasitas ongkos itu termasuk untuk
berkaitan dengan pembiayaan
h
otak dan otot.
Saya punya hobi ada tiga
sekurang-kurangnya ya. Tentu saja adalah
olahraga. Saya suka olahraga, saya suka
lari. Yang kedua hobi saya adalah baca.
Dan yang ketiga, saya suka main dengan
keluarga. Saya suka main dengan anak.
[Musik]
Saya kira apapun yang terjadi ketika
otot lalu kemudian otak dan diikuti
dengan ongkos ini tujuannya menjadi
tidak jelas ya akhirnya memang adalah
berbagai kebijakan yang banyak
problemnya dan menuai perdebatan besar.
Saya kira itu yang mengakibatkan dan
punya sumbangansi besar terhadap
terjadinya
prahara Agustus.
[Musik]
ya dihukum seberatnya lah Pak itu kan
manusia
[Tepuk tangan]
mana keadilan Pakil
mundur dulu Bang dulu, Bang. Nama rakyat
yang disuruh mundur bukan mereka.
Bagaimana seorang ibu yang melihat
anaknya digilas dengan mobil? Sabar
sabar
piada. Prima piada.
[Musik]
Revolusi.
Prahara Agustus sebenarnya tentu saja
bisa dikaitkan dengan apa yang
disampaikan tadi. Plus pada saat yang
sama itu adalah kulminasi dari kemarahan
publik. Kenapa kejadian itu mengalami
eskalasi? ya. Karena kalau kita ingat
ini diawali dengan keputusan DPR untuk
menaikkan tunjangan DPR.
Bahkan ketika tunjangan itu diumumkan
dan kita tahu bahwa tunjangan itu
sebenarnya ada perdebatan karena ada
semacam konflik kepentingan. Dia yang
punya anggaran, dia yang menaikkan.
Tetapi ketika itu mengalami catatan dan
protes dari publik, coba bayangkan
ekspresi tak patut yang dipertontonkan
oleh anggota DTPR di tengah kesusahan
rakyat mereka malah joget-joget.
Kalau Anda lihat di saat masyarakat
sulit mendapatkan pekerjaan seperti
antrian pekerjaan yang Anda lihat ini,
lalu ada rangkaian aksi dari 25 Agustus
hingga awal September yang direpresi
secara brutal di berbagai daerah. Ya,
Avan seorang driver ojol harus menjadi
martir, harus meninggal, dilindas oleh
mobil aparat pada aksi unjur raksa di
Agustus.
Belum lagi kalau kita hitung setidaknya
ada 10 orang yang meninggal dunia dan
tentu kita harus ucapkan doa kepada
mereka. Dan hingga saat ini tidak hanya
soal 10 orang yang meninggal dunia, saat
ini juga ada dua orang yang sampai
sekarang, sampai film ini nanti
ditayangkan, itu masih dua orang yang
dinyatakan hilang.
Angka tidak berhenti di situ. Ada
3.000-an demonstran yang ditangkap.
dan sebanyak 959
orang yang dinyatakan tersangka sebagai
tersangka berkaitan dengan kerusuhan
oleh polisi.
[Musik]
Balik kesalahan 3 O yang tadi sudah
dijelaskan di awal, otot, otak, dan
ongkos. Mudah untuk menciumnya bahwa ini
adalah bagian dari upaya menggunakan itu
terhadap pemilu berikutnya. Tetapi kami
menenggarai sebenarnya bisa jadi ini
bukan hanya berkaitan soal pemenangan
pemilu. Dan karenanya untuk menjelaskan
lebih lanjut saya minta kawan saya Feri
Amsari untuk menjelaskan apa mau
diapakan sebenarnya 3 O ini selain dari
soalan
pemilu.
Siap, Prof. Makasih.
Stay yours.
Baik. Eh sebagaimana disampaikan oleh
Prof. Zainal Arifin Mukhtar
dengan tiga kekuatan otot, otak, dan
ongkos. Apa saja yang bisa digunakan
oleh rezim Prabowo kepada Indonesia?
Pertama, tentu saja sebagaimana
disinggung tadi ini semua untuk
memenangkan Pemilu 2029 nanti.
Meski belum genap 1 tahun, mantan
Presiden Joko Widodo sudah menegaskan
dukungannya agar Presiden Prabowo dan
Gibran akan berlanjut kepada periode
kedua.
Selain kepentingan banyak orang-orang
politik soal kemenangan pemilu itu,
Presiden Prabowo Subianto sendiri punya
dua obsesi lain terkait 3 O itu. Satu,
ingin memastikan kembalinya kapitalisme
terpimpin
sebagai gaya pilihan dalam menjalankan
pemerintahan.
Kedua,
menggunakan upaya pengembalian
Undang-Undang Dasar 1945
sebagai memastikan atau melegitimasi
kekuatan politik nantinya.
Pertanyaan yang menarik dari hal ini
adalah jika semua kepentingan dan
keinginan politik itu
terpenuhi,
yakni menjadi kapitalisme terpimpin
yang memastikan gaya kepemimpinan
terpusat alah Cina terwujud dengan
menggunakan legitimasi kembali kepada
Undang-Undang Dasar 45 naskah awal.
Siapa sesungguhnya yang paling menikmati
keuntungan ini?
Bab ini, chapter ini akan mencoba
menjawabnya.
Sebelum bercerita soal
keuntungan-keuntungan itu,
saya akan coba mengurai ya, bagaimana
kekuatan otot politik digunakan oleh
rezim Prabowo Gibran.
untuk kepentingan jangka pendek
memenangkan Pemilu 2029.
Saya yakin jika teman-teman menyimak
film Dirty Food pertama yang menjelaskan
bagaimana penggunaan politik gentong
babi di mana dana bansos digunakan
mempengaruhi pemilih agar pemilu
berlangsung tidak berimbang dan adil.
Maka sebenarnya ada kesadaran bahwa
penggunaan otot politik itu akan bisa
dimanfaatkan dengan segala keuntungan.
Ingat di film itu dijelaskan gentong
babi melalui bansos menggunakan aparat
penyelenggaraan negara dan desa untuk
kemudian dijalankan sebagai mesin
politik.
Data penelitian dari TEMIS Indonesia
menjelaskan
hal yang sama juga terjadi pada Pilkada
2024 lalu.
Penyebaran bansos dilakukan dan
dikerjakan oleh kepolisian sehingga kita
mengenal istilah partai coklat. Parcok.
Bagaimana cara Parcok memanfaatkan dana
bansos untuk kepentingan politik itu?
Setidak-tidaknya ada beberapa hal.
Pertama,
distribusi bansos itu dilakukan
menjelang hari Pilkada.
Kedua, melibatkan jajaran kepolisian
dari tingkat pusat hingga ke polsek.
ketiga membungkus
penyerahan bansos tersebut dengan
operasi yang dia namakan sebagai cooling
system.
Keempat,
menggunakan serimonial tertentu ya
sebagai momentum khusus agar pembagian
bansos terlihat punya alasan. Mari kita
jelaskan bagaimana kemudian pembagian
bansos ini bisa meluas dan tersebar di
seluruh Indonesia.
Catatan kami
pada Pilkada lalu, Badan Pengawas Pemilu
atau Bawaslu mengeluarkan indeks
kerawanan pemilu dalam hal ini Pilkada
2024.
Indeks kerawanan Pilkada ini memuat
berbagai daerah-daerah yang dianggap
rawan atau berpotensi rawan dalam
tingkatan tertentu. Penentuan status
rawannya sebuah daerah Pilkada itu
dilakukan Bawaslu tentu saja juga
melibatkan Sentra Gakumdu, sentra
penegakan hukum terpadu yang di dalamnya
ada kepolisian dan kejaksaan.
Saya akan menjelaskan melalui gambar ini
hasil dari indeks kerawanan Pilkada
versi Bawaslu. Kalau dilihat di peta ada
gambar merah-merah, wilayah merah-merah.
Ini semua wilayah yang melalui
penelitian Bawaslu dianggap sebagai
daerah yang rawan potensi yang perlu
diredam.
Selain Bawaslu,
pihak kepolisian juga mengeluarkan
indeks kerawanan Pilkada sendiri.
Kami gabungkan dengan indeks kerawanan
versi Bawaslu. Kalau daerahnya sama
antara indeks kerawanan versi Bawaslu
dan kepolisian, maka warnanya akan merah
hitam.
Sementara kalau daerahnya hanya versi
kepolisian diwarnakan warna hitam.
Gambaran ini menjelaskan bahwa daerah
yang rawan akan semakin luas. Dengan
begitu pihak kepolisian punya titik
rawan yang luas yang menjadi argumentasi
untuk digunakan penyelenggaraan
cooling system atau operasi mencegah
terjadinya konflik di lapangan.
Cooling system ini tentu saja sebagai
sesuatu yang dianggap program yang baik
untuk meredam ee konflik yang terjadi
yang dilakukan oleh kepolisian.
Tujuannya menurut polisi baik sekali
karena berupaya mencegah proses
keributan
karena diduga itu berpotensi rawan
karena alasan SARA, suku, agama dan ras.
Ya, ini terlihat bagaimana ee pihak
kepolisian bergerak di segala tempat
untuk memastikan tingkat kerawanan itu
bisa dicegah.
Di lapangan, salah satu bentuk operasi
cooling system ini berupa tentu saja
pembagian bantuan sosial.
Padahal kita ketahui
pembagian bantuan sosial seperti ini
sudah pasti bukan tugas dan kewenangan
kepolisian. Lebih dekat kepada
kewenangan Kementerian atau Dinas
Sosial.
Tapi pembagian bansos sebagai bagian
dari operasi cooling system terjadi
hampir di seluruh wilayah dengan
mempertimbangkan
indeks kerawanan Pilkada itu.
Saya ingin menjelaskan sambil mengambil
contoh data penelitian terhadap tiga
daerah.
pertama adalah Provinsi Banten.
Di Banten
pembagian bantuan sosial berlangsung
dari tanggal 22 25 Juni yang melibatkan
Polda dan Polrest di berbagai daerah di
Jawa di Banten.
Kalau kita perhatikan ya siklus
pembagian bansos
dari tanggal 25 Juni menuju
hariha Pilkada, pembagian bansos oleh
pihak kepolisian berlangsung kian intens
menuju hari H Pilkada. Bisa disimak
di bulan Oktober terjadi upaya
peningkatan pembagian
bansos.
Berikutnya di daerah Provinsi Kalimantan
Timur
sama terjadi pembagian bansos dimulai
dari tanggal 25 Juni melibatkan
berbagai pihak kepolisian dari tingkat
provinsi hingga daerah juga sangat
intens terjadi. Bisa dilihat dari data
proses pembagian bansos ini semua
melibatkan kepolisian dan juga semakin
intens menuju hari-hailkada
sama polanya ya. Ketiga yang menarik
operasi cooling system di Provinsi Jawa
Tengah
ini perlu diperhatikan.
Ini berbeda dengan provinsi yang lain.
Proses pembagian bansos berlangsung
lebih cepat dimulai pada bulan Maret
tanggal 28,
lebih dulu 1 bulan daripada provinsi dan
daerah yang lain. Kedua, yang menarik
adalah terlibatnya
Kapolda Jawa Tengah ketika itu yaitu
Irjen Ahmad Luthfi.
ini pembagian terjadi dan luar biasa
prosesnya.
Tapi ada beberapa hal yang menarik.
Pertama
pada tanggal 11 Juni 2024 Kapolda masih
memberikan bansos
ya di sekitar tanggal ini masih
memberikan bansos hingga tanggal ini.
Dan kemudian dia menyebut operasi
cooling systemnya itu sebagai operasi
yang melibatkan tiga pilar yaitu
kepolisian, militer, dan ASN.
pada tanggal 26 Juli ya
ini berhenti karena Pak Ahmad Luthfi
ditarik ke pusat
menjadi seorang pejabat di Kementerian
Perdagangan
hanya untuk 1 bulan saja. Karena setelah
itu pada tanggal 28 Agustus Pak Ahmad
Luthfi menyatakan diri maju menjadi
calon gubernur Jawa Tengah. Hebat bukan?
Hanya 1 bulan menjabat ditarik ke pusat
lalu kembali untuk mencalonkan diri. Apa
motifnya? Apakah supaya menetralisir
pola pembagian bansos yang sudah
terjadi?
Jadi beliau berhenti di sekitar tanggal
ini untuk membagikan bansos. Hebatnya
lagi meskipun sudah mencalonkan dan
tidak melakukan pembagian bansos,
teman-teman pihak kepolisian tetap
memberikan bantuan bansos hingga
kemudian hari Pilkada berlangsung.
Khusus untuk Pak Ahmad Luthfi,
dukungan dari Presiden Prabowo bahkan
diwujudkan dengan penyampaian terbuka
dukungan terhadap Kapolda Ahmad Luffy di
rumah Presiden Joko Widodo.
Saudara-saudaraku
rakyat Jawa Tengah.
Pada pemilihan kepala daerah yang akan
datang di Jawa Tengah,
saya mohon dengan sangat
berilah suaramu
kepada
Jenderal Ahmad Luffy dan Gus Taj Yasin.
Ya, menyusul video-video ini juga ada
video dukungan Pak Presiden Joko Widodo
terhadap berbagai kepala daerah. Data
menunjukkan banyak hal yang menarik
termasuk dari tiga daerah yang kami
bahas tadi. Ketiga daerah itu
dimenangkan oleh partai presiden, yaitu
Partai Gerindra.
Bisa dilihat di gambar.
Saya ingin menjelaskan bahwa penyebutan
Partai Coklat di era Presiden Joko
Widodo tentu menarik karena beliau
adalah orang sipil.
Sementara di masa Presiden Prabowo yang
background-nya adalah militer,
barangkali kita akan menduga peran
kepolisian akan diciutkan dan diganti
dengan peran dari militer lebih banyak.
Tapi kami berpikir berbeda.
Peran kepolisian tetap akan ada. Tapi
Pak Prabowo juga akan memperkuat peran
rezimnya, peran militer untuk
kepentingan rezimnya.
Meningkatnya peran militer sebagai otot
politik tidak berarti akan mengurangi
peran kepolisian.
Keduanya akan digerakkan bersamaan
sebagai penggerak ganda gardan politik
dari mesin kepentingan untuk memenangkan
pertarungan pada Pemilu 202 nanti.
Bagaimana kita menganalisa peran-peran
ini?
Pertama,
peran militer terus meningkat. ya,
urusan-urusan sipil juga menjadi
urusan-urusan militer sebagaimana apa
yang dilakukan oleh pihak kepolisian,
kita bisa melihat kerjaan militer tidak
hanya masuk menjabat di ruang sipil,
tetapi juga mengerjakan proyek-proyek
Mercu suar.
Bahkan segala sesuatu yang terkait
dengan visi misi presiden seperti proyek
MBG food estet juga diserahkan kepada
militer terutama di Papua.
Militer berdalih bahwa perluasan
definisi pertahanan perlu dipahami oleh
publik. Padahal kita tahu semua bahwa
pertahanan itu bukan urusan yang
berkaitan dengan pangan hingga urusan
yang berkaitan dengan farmasi yang
sedang dikerjakan oleh militer saat ini.
Wajar kemudian cerita partai coklat itu
akan dilanjutkan dengan cerita soal
partai hijau atau Parjo.
urusan yang terus membesar, tanggung
jawab yang besar tentu membutuhkan
personel yang juga harus besar, harus
bertambah. Tadi sudah diurai bahwa ada
penambahan enam qodam baru sehingga
qodam kita sekarang berjumlah 21 qodam
di seluruh Indonesia.
Lalu ada penambahan batalion teritorial
pembangunan.
Keduanya baik Kodam maupun BTP akan
terus bertambah semakin besar menuju
2029 nanti.
Penambahan itu tentu saja tidak sinkron
dengan gagasan pertahanan global yang
diceritakan oleh Presiden Prabowo di
mana-mana.
Penambahan tersebut malah terjadi di
berbagai provinsi yang sebenarnya tidak
matching dengan gagasan pertahanan
global. Kita bisa lihat ada penambahan
kodam di Sumatera Barat, di Jambi, dan
Riau.
Penambahan komando-komando
dan personel ini juga seperti melawan
kehendak zaman soal bagaimana membangun
pertahanan global yang peka dengan
teknologi.
[Musik]
Jika kita lihat video-video tadi, apa
yang disampaikan soal gagasan pertahanan
dengan menambah jum jumlah personel
terasa kian tidak masuk akal dengan
perkembangan pertahanan global yang
mengandalkan teknologi,
mengandalkan AI, mengandalkan perang
ciber, dan mengandalkan bahkan senjata
mikrobiologi.
Sehingga apa yang disampaikan oleh
pemerintah terkesan kontradiktif dengan
gagasan pertahanan dunia global terhadap
perang
militer. Kita justru mengurus urusan
yang jauh dari pertahanan teknologi.
mengurus pangan, hutan, sawah, ladang,
dan jauh sekali gagasan itu dari
cakrawala pertahanan global yang
berlangsung di banyak negara.
Indonesia lebih memilih menambah jumlah
personel.
Konsekuensinya dari penambahan kodam dan
batalion teritorial pertahanan itu
adalah jumlah TNI yang kian membengkak
dengan penambahan personil kira-kira 1
juta personel ke depannya.
Tentu saja urusan yang bertambah dari
mencetak sawah, dari food estek,
terlibat di dalam bisnis hutan,
pertanian hingga mengurus dapur-dapur
MBG membuat pasukan TNI makin jauh dari
barak, makin jauh dari profesionalitas
lembaga pertahanan itu sendiri.
Ada sekitar 32.000
hutan yang terancam di Gunung Mas ini
untuk project Food Estate Singkong ini.
Dan di Indonesia ada lebih dari 3 juta
hektar hutan yang terancam oleh program
project Food Estate ini.
Secara konstitusional
menurut Undang-Undang Dasar Negara kita.
mereposisi kerja militer sebagai petani
mengurus gabah tentu menyalahi
Undang-Undang Dasar 1945.
Pasal 30 Undang-Undang Dasar hanya
menyebutkan tugas TNI hanya pada bidang
pertahanan. Artinya militer hanya
memiliki tugas tunggal memastikan negara
kita aman dari ancaman dan serangan dari
luar. Tidak tugas lain. Mereka TNI kita
terlatih membunuh atau dibunuh, bukan
mencoblos atau dicoblos.
Menjadikan militer tidak profesional itu
merugikan dalam berbagai hal.
Jika militer mengurus pangan, maka
segala infrastruktur terkait dengan
sawah ladang itu merupakan daerah
militer. Konsekuensinya dalam hukum
perang bahwa wilayah itu dapat diserang.
Pekerjaan ganda ini tidak menguntungkan
prajurit itu sendiri.
Personel TNI
seolah-olah banyak tapi tidak bisa
betul-betul melakukan pekerjaan
pertahanan
karena mereka sibuk mengurus hal-hal di
luar pertahanan itu sendiri.
mengurus dapur MBG, menyerap gabah,
hingga mengurus sawah berpotensi
terjadinya gesekan antara TNI dan warga,
TNI dengan petani, TNI dengan lelayan.
Lagi pula perlu kita ingat bahwa ketika
TNI mengerjakan banyak pekerjaan di luar
pertahanan, maka dengan sendirinya itu
menutup kesempatan ruang pekerjaan bagi
masyarakat sipil. Padahal negara sendiri
yang berjanji akan membuka 19 juta
lapangan pekerjaan baru.
Padahal menurut
kita semua, proyek MBG atau food estet
punya banyak konflik antara tentara dan
rakyat sehari-hari. Bahkan Presiden
Prabowo sendiri menyorot soal konflik
ini.
Saya telah diberi laporan oleh
aparat-aparat
bahwa
terdapat
tambang ilegal
dan potensi kekayaan yang dihasilkan
oleh 163
tambang ilegal ini
di
laporkan potensi kerugian negara adalah
minimal 300 triliun.
Saudara-saudara sekalian,
saya minta dukungan
seluruh
MPR.
Saya minta dukungan
seluruh partai politik.
untuk mendukung ini demi rakyat kita,
Saudara-saudara sekalian.
Dan saya beri peringatan,
apakah ada orang-orang besar,
orang-orang kuat,
jenderal-jenderal dari manaun,
apakah jenderal dari TNI atau jenderal
dari polisi atau
atau mantan jenderal?
Tidak ada alasan kami akan bertindak
atas nama rakyat.
Otot politik militer itu berpotensi
meningkat ketika ada upaya memobilisasi
Komcat, komando militer cadangan dan
pengaktifan kembali pasukan pertahanan
masyarakat Swakarsa atau Pam Swakarsa
yang kemudian digunakan untuk
kepentingan tenaga lapangan dalam
pengamanan berbagai bisnis pertanian
maupun proyek strategi. nasional
lainnya.
Bahkan ada ide
merekrut comchat ini gila-gilaan idenya
dilakukan melalui perekrutan narapidana
yang ditargetkan jumlahnya 40.000
narapidana yang akan menjadi Komcat. Ke
depan Komcap ini akan terus bertambah
hingga 700.000 personel.
legitimasinya akan dilakukan dengan
menggunakan peraturan pemerintah dalam
hal ini PP nomor 3 tahun 2021.
Sebagaimana terlihat di layar,
pasal 60 dari PP ini mengatakan bahwa
adalah kewajiban bagi Komchat untuk
dimobilisasi
demi kepentingan militer.
Di sisi yang lain, Pamakarsa
akan digunakan sebagai alat untuk
membubarkan
hak-hak berdemonstrasi, menyuarakan
pendapat.
Bahkan kita bisa lihat peran Pam
Suwakarsa ini di daerah-daerah konflik
di masa lalu, baik di Papua, di
Timur-timur dan lain-lain.
Sebagaimana yang pernah dilakukan di
masa Orde Baru
untuk Pamsuakarsa ini. akan terlihat
relasinya ketika kemudian pimpinan
Pamsuakarsa atau ormas-ormas
berelasi dengan militer untuk digunakan
bagi kebutuhan
dan kepentingan militer.
Hal ini terasa sekali mirip dengan
situasi yang pernah terjadi di era Orde
Baru.
Jika kita bercermin dari pengalaman
militerasi yang terjadi di era Orde Baru
dan pengaktifan peran kepolisian di era
Presiden Joko Widodo,
militer kali ini di era Presiden Prabowo
hendak digunakan sebagai multifungsi di
bawah naungan prinsip militaristik yang
digaungkan oleh Presiden Prabowo.
Inilah otot politik itu.
Apakah memang
ya memang sejak apa saya perintahkan
seperti itu untuk
mendukung pemerintahan
Pak Presiden Prabowo Gibra
dua periode.
Otot politik itu akan digunakan tentu
saja untuk memenangkan Pemilu 2029
sebagaimana terlihat dari video tadi.
Lalu dari mana otot politik sebesar itu
dibiayai? Apa ongkosnya?
Bima Yudistira sekali lagi akan kita
minta untuk menjelaskan dari mana
datangnya ongkos untuk memperkuat otot
politik sebagai suplemen kepentingan
politik itu. Bim hajar Bim. Halo, Bang
Feri. Makasih.
Halo, Bim. Mantap.
Tadi penjelasannya soal militer cukup
menarik tuh.
Wah,
karena kita akan lanjut bicara soal
otot, otak, dan ongkos politik.
Kita akan bedah lagi.
Yes.
Bahwa ini ada kaitan sebenarnya.
Ya.
Jadi, ketika militarisme itu menguat,
He.
Tapi jangan lupa tadi Bang Feri juga
sebutkan ini terkait dengan proyek
strategis nasional. Nah, kalau kita
lihat
tadi ada mandat di dalam Undang-Undang
TNI yang lama maupun yang baru itu salah
satunya adalah operasi militer nonperang
untuk menjaga objek vital nasional. Apa
aja sih sebenarnya objek vital nasional
ini? Salah satunya adalah di
pertambangan nikel.
He.
Ini berbagai kasus di pertambangan
nikel. Tapi juga bukan cuma hanya
pertambangan nikel. He.
Tapi kalau kita lihat ambisi hilirisasi
yang dijadikan sebagai ongkos politik
itu ini dasarnya adalah untuk
meningkatkan nilai tambah di berbagai
jenis komoditas. Jadi kalau dilihat di
sini mulai dari nikel, tembaga, baxit,
dan juga banyak sekali hilirisasi
produk-produk tambang lainnya maupun non
tambang. Ini kalau dilihat nilainya ini
sangat besar. Kita ambil contoh untuk
yang di tambang saja ini Januari sampai
Desember 2024.
itu smelter secara keseluruhan itu nilai
investasinya itu Rp245,2
triliun. Jadi ada nikel, tembaga, baukit
timah dan banyak sekali produk-produk
lainnya. Jadi bisa dibayangkan seberapa
besar kalau kita bicara hilirisasi ini
selain daya rusak lingkungannya besar,
tapi juga bisa dimanfaatkan untuk
memberikan ongkos politik. Kita lihatlah
bagaimana di banyak tempat dan ini
berlanjut dari rezim Jokowi
ya.
Salah satunya adalah kasus di Harita,
kemudian di Morowali, Weda, Obi, Morosi
di berbagai wilayah Sulawesi hingga
Maluku Utara ini menjadi pundi-pundi
uang bagi oligarki nikel yang ada di
Indonesia.
Tapi tidak berhenti pada nikel. Kalau
kita bicara fenomena tutupnya SPBU
swasta
ini ada yang menarik diperhatikan karena
mereka ini kesulitan melakukan impor
dari BBM. Nah, kenapa susah? Karena
sebelumnya ada kondisi di mana Pertamina
itu kalau Bang Feri ingat pada saat itu
ada kasus Pertamina BBM-nya diblending
dengan tidak tepat
atau dioplos. Ya, betul.
Dan itu yang membuat konsumen beralih
dari Pertamina kepada SPBU swasta. Nah,
sekarang SPBU swastanya kuota impornya
habis.
He.
Tapi dengan kuota impor yang habis dan
tidak bisa beroperasi, muncullah ide
untuk satu pintu impornya masuk. Nah,
kalau dilihat nih bedanya nih ya, Bang
Feri. Kalau dulu itu SPBU swasta ini
bisa melakukan importasi langsung.
Namanya juga swasta.
Iya, betul. Tapi kalau sekarang ini
menjadi satu pintu semuanya melakukan
impor kepada Pertamina.
Dan kalau kita lihat importasi di BBM
ini itu juga terjadi pada saat ada
pergantian pemain di dalam Pertamina
untuk impor.
Selain BBM, ada juga yang menjadi ongkos
politik besar yang harus dicermati itu
adalah LNG atau gas alam. Kenapa gas
alam itu menjadi menarik? Di saat
produksi kita turun untuk LNG atau gas
alam, pemerintah punya rencana
membangkit gas
itu 10,3 GW.
Hm.
Ini kan enggak nyambung nih antara
produksi terus. Apa yang terjadi? Jika
produksi terusmenun, kita bangun
pembangkit listrik dari tenaga gas, maka
ke depan kita akan melakukan impor LNG
secara besar-besaran.
Dan LNG secara besar-besaran ditambah
dengan BBM satu pintu untuk impor. Kita
tahulah ini adalah model-model atau
modus yang terjadi pada mafia migas.
I cari
karena rente ekonomi itu besar sekali di
sana.
Benar juga Pak Bahlil Bim. Pantas beliau
jadi doktor ya. Ya, itu Abang bukan
promotor ya kan?
Bukan.
Nah, tiga tadi ini adalah pundi pundi
dari uang yang akan masuk ke dalam
kantong elit.
Hm.
Jadi kita bicara elit tapi juga kita
bicara bahwa di level grass root selain
elit tadi mendapatkan banyak sekali
keuntungan, tapi juga kita bicara di
grass root dan circle politik ini
terkait dengan koperasi Desa Merah
Putih.
Oke.
Nah, kenapa ini menjadi menarik? Karena
Selios
pernah memiliki survei kepada perangkat
desa, hasilnya 35% responden yang
merupakan perangkat desa itu percaya
bahwa COPDES ini adalah syarat
kepentingan politik.
Oke.
Jadi kalau kita punya simulasi, tiap
koperasi itu punya 100 anggota dengan
total basis 8 juta anggota. Ini bisa
dikonversi Bang Feri itu untuk apa?
untuk pendukung pada saat Pemilu 2029 ke
depan. Jadi, ada potensi konversi ke
kursi DPR itu 34 sampai dengan 46 kursi.
Nah, tentu ini kan tergantung ya
siapapun bisa memanfaatkan ini. Tapi
dengan kondisi sekarang di mana
konsolidasi politik itu terjadi, kita
tahulah bahwa ini semua akan menguatkan
rezim yang ada sekarang ini.
Nah, survei yang tadi dilakukan oleh
Selios itu juga sejalan dengan adanya
perombakan kabinet.
Oke.
Jadi, kalau kita lihat ya, Bu Sri
Mulyani diganti ke Purbaya.
Apa yang menarik?
Ada cara-cara baru untuk mendukung
program prioritas termasuk COPDES itu
dengan injeksi 200 triliun dari dana
pemerintah yang dititipkan ke Bank
Indonesia itu dipindahkan ke Bank
Himbara untuk kasih pinjaman dengan
bunga murah ke Kopdes Merah Putih.
Oke.
Tapi yang menarik lagi pergantian pemain
Budi Ari ini kan orang dekatnya Jokowi.
Iya. Relawannya Jokowi diganti ke Feri
Juliantono. Siapa Feri Juliantono? Ini
adalah kader internalnya Partai Gerinda.
Partai Gerindra Pak Prabowo dekat. Yang
menarik adalah model ini hampir mirip
dengan yang terjadi pada bansos biasanya
ya. Karena bansos ini sangat seksi, maka
Kementerian Sosial itu diperebutkan oleh
banyak partai. Sehingga Prabowo ingin
memastikan bahwa Kopdes Merah Putih ini
menjadi program yang memang harus
diawasi dari dekat
oleh Pak Prabowo sendiri.
Nah, tapi saya jadi teringat dari Tot
pertama
yang menjelaskan kecurangan melibatkan
80.000 desa.
Hm. Jumlah itu hampir sama mendekati
dengan jumlah koperasi merah putih
bukan?
Ada kemiripan berarti.
Ada kemiripan ya.
Polanya bisa jadi hampir sama.
I
tapi yang menjadi pertanyaan begitu
Purbaya injeksi Rp200 triliun
bisa dipakai oleh bank milik pemerintah
atau BUMN. Padahal sebenarnya ada loh
uang menganggur R80 triliun di bank
milik pemerintah. Pertanyaannya, buat
apa injeksi lagi
kalau uangnya ada?
Kalau ada uangnya nganggur.
Jadi ini kelihatan sekali bahwa sebagian
200 triliun yang digunakan untuk
koperasi Desa Merah Putih itu artinya
memang ini untuk program-program yang
prioritas
dan itu 200 triliun tadi itu bukan uang
gratisan
ya. Sekali lagi itu adalah uang
pemerintah yang didapatkan dari pajak
ataupun utang baru.
Oke.
Kalau dilihat tadi Bang Feri pernah
bicara soal apa yang terjadi dengan dana
desa. He.
Ini kita juga tanya nih dalam survei
yang dilakukan oleh Selios, ternyata 65%
korupsi itu sangat mungkin terjadi kalau
tata kelola Kopdes Merah Putih seperti
sekarang.
Hm. Jadi artinya ada potensi
penyelewengan.
Dulu kasus dana desa desa
itu tercatat menjadi kasus yang cukup
heboh dan jelang pemilu.
I
itu tiba-tiba muncul berbagai jenis
kasus. Nah, sebagai contoh misalnya ya
di sini ada di Jawa Tengah itu muncul
kasus di Tegal, Sukoharjo, Magelang,
Blora, Wonogiri. Jadi peta ini itu
menunjukkan bahwa pilihannya ada dua.
Bagi perangkat desa yang mendukung
program pemerintah tidak berseberangan,
dia bisa jadi akan diputihkan.
Oke.
Tapi bagi mereka yang berseberangan
itu justru bisa dipidanakan atau
dikriminalisasi ya bahasa lainnya. Nah,
ini juga dikhawatirkan oleh masyarakat
seperti kesaksian yang kita akan lihat
nih dari kepala desa
berikut ini.
Kalau ancaman sih ee secara langsung sih
tidak ya, cuma secara ee daring kemulut
di antara kami selaku kepala desa ya
katanya ee tidak bisa ee pencana desa
kita akan ditunda yang tahap dua. ee
sampai sekarang kami masih agak ee apa
ya masih bimbang untuk
melakukan peminjaman ke Himbara gitu.
Kenapa kami agak bimbang? Karena ee
yang menjadi jaminan untuk peminjaman
ini kalau seandainya ee pengurus
koperasi desa tidak mampu untuk membayar
angsuran, jaminannya adalah dana desa.
Nah, itu yang menjadi salah satu apa ya
kekhawatiran bagi kami di pemerintahan
desa.
Nanti kalau seandainya ee pengurus
koperasi tidak mampu untuk membayarkan
cicilannya, otomatis dana desa tentunya
akan terserap ke sandar. Nah, apalagi
nanti kalau seandainya ee unit usaha
atau gerai koperasi Desa Merah Putih
mengalami kerugian ya, mau tidak mau
yang dikorbankan tentunya adalah dana
desa yang kita dapatkan dari ee
pemerintah pusat.
Karena itu ada simpan pinjam namanya
masyarakat kita suruh lagi ke masyarakat
kan gak mungkin
masyarakat tahunya itu adalah
duit negara iki uang negara katanya
padahal uang negara itu yang harus
ada pertanggungjawaban wajib. Nanti
kalau simpan pinjam pengurus Kis merah
putihnya kasihan dong diperiksa-periksa
duitnya enggak ada. Padahal
yang
permasalahannya itu tidak diangsur rutin
tiap bulan gitu.
Nah, itu tadi kesaksian dari para kepala
desa yang sebenarnya mereka juga bingung
tapi juga khawatir
bahwa ini bisa jadi semacam alat politik
untuk bisa memperoleh suara pada waktu
pemilu ke depan. Tapi kalau kita lihat
ada juga sebenarnya potensi yang lainnya
yaitu mereka akan melakukan pengampunan.
Siapa? Pak Prabowo itu pernah melakukan
penghapusan piutang macet dari UMKM.
Jadi ini semua bisa digunakan untuk
kepentingan Pilpres 2029.
Selain kepentingan Pilpres itu, otot,
otak, dan ongkos 3O yang dipupuk oleh
Pra-Prabowo itu, itu juga bisa
meningkatkan
percepatan agar ide kapitalisme
terpimpin itu bisa terwujud. Oke,
jadi ada kaitannya. Dan sejak lama
sebenarnya Prabowo cukup tergila-gila
dengan konsep yang namanya state
capitalism, kapitalisme negara atau
kapitalisme terpimpin. Contohnya adalah
pada buku Paradoks Indonesia dan
Solusinya ya. Yang
Pak Prabowo sendiri ya.
Iya. Karangan Pak Prabowo sendiri. Coba
kita cek di halaman 28 misalnya itu ada
satu kutipan yang menarik bahwa cabang
produksi penting itu yang menguasai
hidup orang banyak dan seluruh sumber
daya alam itu dikuasai oleh negara dan
dia mengutip bahwa ini yang dilakukan
Tiongkok
yang sebenarnya luput dilakukan atau
dikerjakan serius oleh Indonesia
sendiri. Tapi kalau kita lihat juga di
halaman berikutnya, di halaman 29,
ada kutipan juga yang menarik dari buku
Paradoks Indonesia. Dengan kata lain,
kita tidak secara sungguh-sungguh
menjalankan pasal 33 Undang-Undang Dasar
1945 sementara Tiongkok menjalankannya.
Jadi dia pengin bilang bahwa harus ada
konsistensi. Kalau kita mau jadi kayak
China berarti kita harus punya kontrol
terhadap berbagai sumber daya seperti
dal pasal 33 ya
dengan dalinya. Tapi pasal 33
I.
Nah, inilah yang membuat kita melihat
ada kekaguman dari Pak Prabowo secara
pribadi itu kagum dengan China karena ia
menganggap yang dilakukan oleh China itu
itu selaras misalnya dengan pasal 33
dan punya model kapitalisme negara.
Jangan lupa juga China itu
pertumbuhan ekonominya pernah double
digit.
Oh,
jadi pernah lebih dari 10%. Satu lagi
adalah kekaguman dengan reformis China
yang namanya Den Shia. Karena Denoping
yang bisa mereformasi dengan banyak
sekali industri-industri baru
bermunculan di China.
Tapi
pertanyaannya Bang Feri, untuk menjadi
seperti China, Prabowo punya beberapa
syarat
h
yang ingin dicapai. Yang pertama adalah
koalisi partai besar. Kita lihat
sekarang konsolidasi politik terjadi.
Bahkan konsolidasi ini artinya tidak ada
oposisi.
Oposisi sama sekali
ya. Tapi kan China partai tunggal
sementara kita multiartai.
Tapi koalisi tunggal.
Nah, tapi koalisinya sepertinya koalisi
tunggal.
Kemudian butuh tentara yang kuat.
H
di China itu ada yang namanya strategi
military civil fusion.
Apa tuh?
Atau penggabungan antara fungsi-fungsi
militer ke dalam sipil. Wah, mirip ya.
Oke, kemudian ada lagi pengkonsolidasian
kapital ini. Mereka juga punya semacam
Danantara. Jadi, Danantara itu Indonesia
dengan China punya kemiripan. Sofrend
world fund-nya mengkonsolidasikan
aset-aset dari BUMN. Tapi yang menarik
nih, resentralisasi kekuasaan.
Jadi sentralisasi kekuasaan ini bukan
hanya pada bidang keamanan, ideologi
jelas, tapi juga terkait dengan ekonomi.
Tentu kita ingat ada kejadian menarik
konglomerat dari China,
Jackma itu
I ya. itu saking besar konglomerasinya
tapi dianggap tidak patuh terhadap alat
dari polit biro
ataupun kuasa dari polit biro sehingga
yang terjadi dia disingkirkan oleh
kekuasaan polit biro di China. Nah, itu
yang artinya konglomerat tidak boleh
durhaka pada pemerintah yang berkuasa
ya. Setelah kemudian kita menuju pada
otoritarianisme,
mengorbankan demokrasi, bahkan daya
rusak lingkungannya cukup besar,
kebebasan sipil, kebebasan pers, dan
menguatnya militerisme. Pertanyaannya
Bang Feri,
ya
ini hasilnya akan seperti China atau
Singapura?
Heeh.
Atau
hasilnya akan beda? Tapi mungkin
penjelasan saya agak kompleks,
agak serius. Agak serius ini jadinya.
Tapi kita lihatlah yang lebih ahli akan
menjelaskannya lewat video berikut ini.
Wah, ini asik nih yang lebih ahli.
Kenapa lu yakin banget bakal jadi Cina
sama Vietnam?
Apa jaminan yang enggak bakal jadi Korea
Utara, Somalia, Zimbabwe? AP curang
emang
enggak.
Jadi begitu Bang Feri gambaran dari
otoritarianisme.
Keren, keren, keren. Thank you, Dim.
Setahun ini hobi yang saya jalani biasa
ya, makan, pergi di tempat yang jauh,
lalu makan lagi, ketemu orang dan makan
lagi.
[Musik]
Penjelasan Bima
menjelaskan banyak hal. Saya juga akan
memulai menjelaskan pandangan yang
berkaitan dengan penjelasan Bima. Foto
ini menjelaskan banyak hal.
Dari empat orang yang ada di dalam foto,
dua di antaranya merupakan penggagas
otoritarianisme
tanpa demokrasi, yaitu Presiden Cina
Zijin Ping dan Presiden Korea Utara Kim
Jong Un.
Cina dan Korea Utara memang contoh bahwa
tanpa demokrasi
sebuah negara juga bisa bertahan, bisa
kaya. Cina bahkan membuktikan bahwa
tanpa demokrasi mereka bisa mengatur
perekonomian dunia bahkan menjadi negara
besar dan maju. Tak ada oposisi.
Kebebasan bicara dibatasi dan ekonomi
dikendalikan oleh kuasa negara. Persis
penjelasan Bima tadi. Dalam kasus Cina
dan Rusia yang diwakili oleh Putin,
orang bisa sangat kaya dan berkuasa.
Meski kedua-duanya pernah ya memahami
konsep komunisme.
Khusus Vladimir Putin, ia telah mengubah
Undang-Undang Dasarnya, Konstitusinya
untuk bisa berkuasa panjang.
Bahkan kalau dilihat prosesnya, dia
sudah berkuasa 13 tahun. Kalau
diperhatikan perubahan konstitusinya,
dia bahkan bisa menambah 12 tahun lagi
untuk terus berkuasa hingga tahun 2036.
Sebuah periode yang sangat panjang. Ide
mengubah konstitusi untuk perpanjangan
periode sebenarnya juga tidak asing di
kita. Kita mendengar ketika era Presiden
Joko Widodo mau berakhir, beliau dan
segala pendukungnya menggagas soal
perpanjangan periode presiden.
Memang harus diakui gejala
otoritarianisme sedang mewabah di
berbagai negara di dunia. Tak terkecuali
Amerika dengan Donald Trump-nya. Bahkan
Donald Trump ketika periode keduanya di
awal sudah mendeklarasikan oleh
dukungannya, para pendukungnya untuk
menjabat hingga tiga periode.
Lalu bagaimana dengan Presiden Prabowo?
Selain dekat dengan para otokrat Rusia
dan Cina lewat berbagai organisasi,
salah satunya Bricks,
bukan berarti Presiden Prabowo itu anti
Donald Trump.
Dia terlibat lobi dengan Donald Trump
melakukan hubungan dagang kerja sama
dengan berbagai teknologi.
reg
[Musik]
yeah that's
I I har also I
Yeah, but we look for better place.
Yeah.
Video tersebut tentu saja tidak
menceritakan Pak Prabowo adalah
antek-antek asing ya, tetapi menjelaskan
bahwa tidak hanya di urusan perdagangan
mereka membangun koalisi. Bahkan di
politik luar negeri sekalipun Pak
Prabowo lebih dekat kepada blok Amerika
dengan gagasan urusan Israel
Palestinanya.
Ini terkesan strategi bermain dua kaki
dan terasa sekali bahwa ini jauh dan
berseberangan dengan gagasan politik
luar negeri bebas aktif yang dirancang
bangsa Indonesia.
Jadi relasi baik dengan Donald Trump,
dengan Putin dan Jinping sebenarnya
punya satu kesamaan
bahwa mereka semua sama memiliki watak
otoriter.
Dan harus diingat ada di dalam DNA-nya
Presiden Prabowo
watak otoriter tersebut kita bisa
melihat dengan berbagai faktor sejarah.
Maka melihat politik luar negeri Prabowo
sebenarnya tidak mewakili karakter
Indonesia. Prabowo mendekati Zinping
bukan karena ia muak dengan dominasi
politik Barat.
Prabowo dekat dengan Putin bukan karena
ia anti Uni Eropa dan Prabowo bersama
Donald Trump juga bukan karena ia
mengagumi demokrasi alam Amerika.
Ini bukan soal isu utara
dan selatan seperti era Soekarno yang
menyatukan negara-negara bekas jajahan
di konferensi Asia-Afrika untuk melawan
dominasi blok barat dan timur. Ini bukan
pula soal bricks melawan dominasi
ekonomi Amerika dan Uni Eropa, tetapi
karena Pak Prabowo nyaman dengan boys
club ini, klub para otokrat ini, dan
ingin memastikan kekuasaannya tidak
diganggu gugat sebagaimana pernah
dilakukan pihak luar
mantan mertuanya.
Pak Prabowo memang tidak nyaman dengan
demokrasi.
butuh empat kali pemilu presiden agar
beliau bisa menang. Itu sebabnya Pak
Prabowo menyebut demokrasi sebagai
sesuatu yang mahal, kacau, dan
melelahkan.
Tidak ada orang yang dia menang pemilu
dalam sebuah sistem kemudian
mempertanyakan sistem itu, kecuali
memang dia terpaksa mengikuti sistem itu
untuk meraih keuntungannya.
atau kekesalan pada sistem demokrasi
juga bisa membuat orang melakukan
berbagai kecurangan melalui proses
demokrasi yang ada meskipun melanggar
etik sebagai sesuatu yang menurut mereka
hal yang wajar saja dilakukan.
very very tiring.
Democracy is very very messy.
Democracy is very very costly.
Namun bagaimana kemudian
mengubah sebuah sistem yang sudah
berlangsung 27 tahun sejak reformasi 98?
Gagasannya
bisa dilihat dari ADR. Partai Gerindra.
Mereka menginginkan kembali kepada
naskah awal Undang-Undang Dasar 45.
Dengan mengubah kembali konstitusi, maka
potensi mengendalikan politik jauh lebih
mudah. Termasuk ingin menjadi presiden
selama mantan mertuanya berlangsung
mungkin lebih dari 32 tahun.
Tapi gagasan mengembalikan Undang-Undang
Dasar 45 ini tidak hanya di-support oleh
Partai Gerindra, bahkan Forum
Purnawirawan TNI pun menggagas hal yang
sama. Karena bagi mereka dengan kembali
kepada Undang-Undang Dasar 45 naskah
awal, maka dominasi dan peran militer
yang penting dapat kembali diwujudkan.
Dan tentu saja menumpuknya kekayaan
dalam melaksanakan kepentingan itu. Bagi
saya dan teman-teman,
menjaga dan merawat konstitusi kita
hasil reformasi amat penting. Sebab
berkaitan dengan enam agenda reformasi.
Kalau kita mau lihat enam agenda
reformasi itu satu persatu dihancurkan.
Misalnya agenda pertama
adili Soeharto dan kroninya. Ini hampir
tidak mungkin lagi terjadi.
Tidak mungkin kita mengadili Soeharto.
Bahkan kroni-kroninya
muncul dan tumbuh kembali bahkan jadi
presiden. Kedua, hapusnya di fungsi ABRI
tidak mungkin lagi dilakukan ketika
kemudian revisi Undang-Undang TNI muncul
dengan memastikan konsep multifungsi
TNI. Bayangkan lebih dari ini, ini juga
gagal. Ketiga,
cita-cita otonomi daerah seluas-luasnya.
Bisa dikatakan begitu Undang-Undang
Cipta Kerja muncul, maka seluruh
kewenangan daerah kembali ditarik ke
pusat. Sekali lagi ada sentralistik di
Jakarta yang mengendalikan berbagai
kepentingan daerah. Ini juga gagal.
Berikutnya soal menegakkan supremasi
hukum. Bagaimana kita bisa mengatakan
bahwa supremasi hukum tegak ketika
undang-undang dan segala kebijakan hanya
diperuntukkan dan dibuat agar
kepentingan elit politik bisa terus
berlanjut. Ini menuju kita juga gagal.
Soal pemerintahan yang bersih dan bebas,
korupsi, kolusi, nepotisme, KKN. Kita
tidak merasa ini sudah bisa diuji.
Ketika dunia peradilan membuka ruang
nepotisme agar Gibran bisa maju walaupun
berbeda dengan cara yang ditentukan oleh
undang-undang. Jadi, KKN terus
berlangsung. Satu-satunya agenda
reformasi yang tersisa dan belum
dihancurkan adalah amandemen
Undang-Undang Dasar 45.
Ini adalah kekuatan masyarakat sipil.
Kenapa kemudian kita harus
mempertahankan Undang-Undang Dasar 45
hasil reformasi?
Setidak-tidaknya karena beberapa hal.
Pertama,
Undang-Undang Dasar ini memastikan
kedaulatan ada di tangan rakyat, bukan
di tangan MPR, bukan di tangan elit.
Rakyat menentukan banyak hal. Kedua,
Presiden dipilih oleh MPR.
Kalau kita kembali kepada Undang-Undang
Dasar naskah awal, padahal rakyatlah
yang menentukan siapa yang berhak
menjadi orang nomor satu di republik
ini, bukan elit. Ketiga, tidak ada
batasan masa jabatan jika kita kembali
kepada Undang-Undang Dasar Naskah Awal
bisa berlangsung 32 tahun, 21 tahun. Dan
ini pula yang diinginkan oleh berbagai
pihak sebelum Pak Presiden Joko Widodo
lengser perpanjangan masa jabatan.
Keempat, tidak ada pasal yang bicara
soal KPU yang independen dan pemilu
berlangsung dengan jujur dan adil. Itu
sebabnya menurut saya rencana
mengembalikan Undang-Undang Dasar 45
kepada naskah awal adalah memastikan
dominasi kekuasaan itu terjadi. Kelima
yang paling penting adalah di dalam
Undang-Undang Dasar 45 naskah awal tidak
terdapat pengaturan yang spesifik soal
hak azazi manusia. Bab yang mengatur
pasal 28 dan turunannya tidak terdapat
di ketentuan ini. Padahal pengaturan ini
sangat penting. Mengubah Undang-Undang
Dasar agar kembali seperti era Orde Baru
tentu bisa dilakukan oleh rezim Prabowo
Gibran.
Tentu ini akan membuat mereka semakin
populer dan akan mampu membawa gagasan
ekonomi kapitalisme terpimpin terus.
terwujud dengan bantuan Jinping,
Putin, bahkan mungkin Donald Trump.
Untuk mewujudkan itu,
Prabowo
akan rela melakukan apa saja,
melakukan tarif dagang dan impor gandum
bahkan buing dengan raksasa ekonomi
dunia. termasuk kemudian menggadaikan
cita-cita Indonesia dalam isu seperti
Israel dan Palestina.
Saat ini jika rezim berhasil
mengkonsolidasikan
otot, otak, dan ongkos
dari level lokal mulai dari makan
bergizi gratis sampai dengan elit
global, saat itulah apapun yang rezim
ini inginkan akan dapat diwujudkan.
Bahkan dukungan seperti dari Rusia dan
Cina mungkin bisa terjadi. Pertanyaannya
adalah
siapakah yang paling diuntungkan jika
konstitusi mundur ke belakang? Ya, di
mana rezim Prabowo Gibran mendominasi
berbagai hal?
Jawabannya
ada di dalam karakter ekonomi Cina itu
sendiri. Dan dari pengalaman Indonesia
di bawah rezim era Orde Baru. Semacam
ada percumbuhan di antara dua gagasan
ekonomi. Kapitalisme terpimpin ala Cina
dikawinkan dengan kapitalisme kroni di
era Orde Baru.
Dalam sistem yang demikian, tentu saja
oligarki akan terus mendominasi,
kekayaan akan makin terpusat dan
dikendalikan oleh segelintir orang
seperti apa yang terjadi di Cina, Rusia,
dan bahasa era kejayaan Orde Baru.
Di sisi yang lain, kekayaan itu
bersumber dari sektor ekstraktif seperti
pertambangan, perkebunan, skala besar,
hingga penguasaan properti.
yang banyak memicu kerusakan alam dan
konflik agraria di antara masyarakat.
Maka kapitalisme terpimpin yang
diimpikan oleh Prabowo dan perubahan
konstitusi untuk melindunginya
punya satu tujuan,
yaitu oligarki terus berkuasa di
Indonesia.
Mungkin Anda tidak percaya, tapi Anda
perlu menyimak apa yang pernah diucapkan
oleh Presiden Prabowo di hadapan para
pebisnis.
Apagi tentara, tentara itu mission,
mission, mission. Jadi aku sudah kena
brain kan. Tugas-tugas yang penting
tugas. Enggak peduli gue sakiti siapa,
gue injek siapa. Ya kan berhasil.
Iya, gue berhasil tapi yang jongkol
banyak.
Makanya gue kalah kalah terus jadi
presiden
ya.
kayaknya dulu gua enggak diundang ke
forum seperti ini.
Ini gara-gara pandu ini sama
Tohir lagi ketua tim kampanyenya sana ya
kan.
Untung dia sudah ditambah gue sekarang.
Relasi dengan para konglomerat ini tentu
saja akan menghasilkan sistem politik
yang rusak dan korup di mana
pemerintahan akan semakin otokratik dan
melupakan inti bernegara yaitu
memastikan daulat dan kesejahteraan
rakyat. Bagi saya inilah lingkaran setan
antara kekuasaan, aparat, politik, uang,
dan kekayaan.
otot, otak, dan ongkos.
Tapi apakah kita hanya bisa menjadi
penonton dari segala ketamakan ini atau
kita mampu melakukan sesuatu
bersama-sama?
Untuk urusan solusi saya ingin kita
semua mendengarkan penjelasan Bitri
Susanti. Mbak silakan Mbak mainkan Mbak
Bibip.
Mari kita mainkan.
[Musik]
Kalau hobi saya memang hobinya hobi saya
naik gunung. Enggak harus naik gunung
yang serius ee 3.000 m ke atas, tapi
bahkan kadang-kadang kalau lagi suntuk
banget saya suka jalan-jalan aja yang
dekat-dekat yang penting kembali ke
alam.
[Musik]
Harus semangat dong karena kita akan
berbicara soal solusi di chapter yang
ketiga ini. Tadi seperti yang sudah
diungkapkan dalam bagian pertama dan
kedua. Pada bagian ketiga ini kita akan
melihat bagaimana solusi memutus
lingkaran setan tadi. Kita sudah
menemukan tiga institusi yang
bertanggung jawab pada situasi yang hari
ini kita hadapi. Yang pertama adalah
kepolisian, yang kedua TNI, dan yang
ketiga sistem politik. Reformasi polisi
dan reformasi TNI perlu kita lakukan
untuk mengembalikan fungsi otot untuk
kepentingan negara, bukan untuk
kepentingan sebagian kecil orang yang
tadi dijelaskan. Sedangkan perombakan
sistem politik kita membicarakan
bagaimana supaya otot atau otak dan
ongkos itu diarahkan untuk kepentingan
rakyat. Pada akhirnya nanti sistem
politik yang akan kita bangun adalah
sistem politik yang lebih inklusif bagi
warga.
Kita mesti mulai pertama-tama dengan
reformasi polisi.
[Tepuk tangan]
Main sini B.
Kekerasan polisi seperti yang barusan
kita lihat adalah tema utama yang
dialami oleh semua orang belakangan ini.
Saya yakin Anda semua merasa relate
dengan apa yang baru kita lihat. Dan
semua kekerasan ini korbannya adalah
kita.
Dan kita tidak mesti jadi demonstran
untuk jadi korban. Bahkan kita kebetulan
lewat kita bisa menjadi korban. Jangan
lupa Afan Kurniawan
mati di lindas mobil polisi ketika dia
hanya sedang mengantarkan pesanannya
karena dia adalah driver ojol.
Coba kita lihat angkanya. Setidaknya
dalam 5 tahun terakhir,
coba kita bawa dulu ke sebelumnya. di 5
tahun terakhir dalam catatan yang kita
tampilkan di depan pada bulan Juli 2020
sampai Juni 2021 misalnya ada 651 kasus.
Kita bisa lihat rata-rata di atas 600
setiap tahun mestinya tentu saja nol.
Polisi tidak boleh jadi pelaku
kekerasan.
Bahkan tidak berhenti di sini. Kita juga
punya angka yang akan mengejutkan kita
semua. Karena tidak hanya kekerasan yang
tadi kita lihat dalam video barusan,
tapi kekerasan ini juga menyebabkan
kematian.
Di sini misalnya kita melihat pada bulan
pada tahun 2023 sampai 2024 ada 37 orang
yang tewas karena kita sebut
extrajudicial killing atau sebuah
pembunuhan. yang dilakukan oleh aparat
penegak hukum tapi di luar pengadilan.
Sedangkan antara Juli 2024 sampai Juni
2025 ada 40 orang yang tewas. Tapi
kekerasan ini hanya puncak gunung es. Di
tubuh kepolisian semacam ada bibit
penyakit yang sampai sekarang sulit
sekali untuk kita bongkar. Sampai-sampai
luapan kemarahan itu tidak berhenti di
grutuan kita, tapi juga kita nanti akan
melihat beberapa tagar yang muncul tapi
juga mural
sampai akhirnya ada tuntutan yang
dilancarkan oleh sebagian pihak setelah
prahara Agustus. Tadi juga disampaikan
oleh Gerakan Nurani Bangsa perlunya
evaluasi dan reformasi kepolisian yang
disambut juga oleh Pak Presiden akan
segera ee membentuk tim atau Komisi
reformasi kepolisian. Saya kira ini juga
atas tuntutan dari masyarakat yang cukup
banyak. Makasih.
Para sesepuh ini tentu saja bukan
demonstran yang pada bulan Agustus ada
di jalanan. Tapi bahkan mereka sudah
menyadari bahwa
reformasi kepolisian itu sangat-sangat
dibutuhkan sekarang juga. Kalau tadi
kita melihat
kekerasan yang terjadi di jalanan,
bahkan ironisnya kekerasan itu terjadi
di markas kepolisian sendiri. Kita bisa
melihat beberapa catatan kasus yang saya
kira semua kita masih ingat. Misalnya
ada kasus Ferdi Sambo dan Teddy
Minahasa. Sebut saja itu karena yang
lainnya begitu banyak yang bisa
diungkapkan. Tapi perhatikan pembunuhan,
narkoba, korupsi, penyuapan, kekerasan
seksual terhadap anak. Bayangkan
penggelapan BBM. Kita tarik satu
misalnya kasus Ferdi Sambo.
Yang ironis dari kasus Ferdi Sambo
adalah ketika pembunuhan berlangsung,
Ferdi Sambo adalah ketua divisi profesi
dan pengamanan yang urusannya adalah
soal pengawasan internal kepolisian.
Bayangkan bahwa seorang jenderal
menembak anak buahnya sendiri.
Atau kasus lainnya Irjen Tedi Minahasa.
Waktu itu
ia adalah eh Kapolda Sumatera Barat dan
ia mengungkap sebuah kasus besar
peredaran sabu 41 kg waktu itu
jumlahnya. Tapi yang unik, seorang
Kapolda.
ia menjual barang bukti itu. Bayangkan
itu bisa terjadi dalam sebuah institusi
penegakan hukum.
Di saat yang sama sebenarnya juga kita
bisa melihat banyak sekali
impunitas yang terjadi di dalam aparat,
di dalam tubuh institusi kepolisian.
Impunitas di sini adalah semacam upaya
untuk menutup-nutupi sebuah kasus, untuk
membuat menciptakan kekebalan dalam
sebuah institusi karena ada kedekatan
dari orang-orang yang melakukan
kejahatan itu dengan atasannya, dengan
elit politik ataupun dengan orang-orang
yang memiliki kekuasaan. Nah, kita bisa
lihat di sini ada beberapa kasus mulai
dari kasus novel Baswedan, demo Bawaslu,
tadi kita lihat sedikit videonya tragedi
Kanjuruhan
sampai dengan kasus Afif Maulana dan
kasus Gama. Kita ambil lagi sampelnya
misalnya di sini kasus novel Baswedan
2017.
Novel Basweldan adalah mantan penyidik
KPK dan waktu itu ia disiram air keras
terkena matanya dan ee itu dilakukan
dugaannya adalah karena kasus IKTP yang
melibatkan Setian Novanto.
Saya waktu itu adalah salah satu anggota
tim gabungan Pencari Fakta yang dibentuk
oleh Komnas HAM. ada dua anggota PORI
yang ditangkap, tapi sebenarnya
rangkaian kasusnya dan siapa yang
memerintahkan dan seterusnya tidak
pernah diungkap sampai sekarang. Lalu
kita juga melihat kasus Kanjuruhan
waktu itu polisi menembakkan gas air
mata ke dalam sebuah pertandingan bola
dalam sebuah stadion yang tertutup.
Memang ada beberapa orang yang diberi
sanksi ee penjara, tapi kasus ini tidak
pernah sampai membongkar. Ini
tuntutannya sebenarnya membongkar
bagaimana seharusnya polisi menghadapi
massa. Kedua, bagaimana seharusnya gas
air mata itu diperlakukan. Dan yang
ketiga, bagaimana sebenarnya SOP-nya
penggunaan gas air mata itu. Jangankan
sampai ke upaya membongkar itu semua,
bahkan
waktu awal polisi malah menyalahkan
angin yang menerbangkan gas air mata.
Dan jangan lupa, jangan pernah lupa. Ada
kasus Gama Octavandi di Semarang
yang waktu itu seorang siswa SMK umurnya
baru 17 tahun waktu itu. Ee polisi
penembaknya memang diberi sanksi waktu
itu. Waktu itu ee Gama sedang naik motor
kemudian dia ditembak. Tapi yang ingin
atau yang harus disoroti adalah awalnya
polisi merekayasa narasi. yang
ditampilkan adalah senjata tajam seperti
ini untuk menimbulkan kesan bahwa waktu
itu Gama memang harus dihentikan karena
dia membawa senjata tajam. Padahal
terbukti di pengadilan
ini tidak benar sama sekali dan ini
adalah upaya membentuk narasi publik
yang tidak boleh dilakukan oleh aparat
penegak hukum. Praktik impunitas seperti
ini memang sering sekali terjadi. Tadi
datanya sudah kita lihat. sehingga kita
harus melihat sebenarnya pengawasannya
seperti apa. Karena impunitas maupun
kekerasan bisa terjadi terus-menerus
bertahun-tahun karena tidak ada
pengawasan. Kalau kita lihat model
pengawasan di tubuh kepolisian, tentu
saja ada pengawasan internal kemudian
eksternal. Yang internal eh kita tadi
saya sudah sebut satu kali misalnya
divisi profesi dan pengamanan. Kemudian
nanti ada sidang etik dan sanksi
disiplin. Tapi ada pengawasan eksternal.
Kita bisa lihat ada Kompolnas tapi juga
Komnas HAM, Ombutsman kita sendiri kalau
melapor dan DPR RI.
Kita soroti dulu internalnya.
internalnya kembali kita harus melihat
apa yang terjadi dengan kasus Ferdi
Sambo.
Kita perlu soroti di sini yang ironis
adalah ada dua hal sebenarnya yang perlu
kita soroti. Pertama, lihatlah perilaku
orang-orang yang terlibat dalam kasus
ini. Membantu back, membantu
menghilangkan CCTV,
menghapus,
kemudian ada otak utamanya tentu saja.
Kemudian juga ada ee memerintahkan
perubahan tempat kejadian perkara dan
seterusnya.
polisi sendiri yang melakukan
tindakan-tindakan seperti ini. Tapi soal
yang kedua adalah semuanya kita bisa
lihat yang berwarna biru, semua yang
melakukan hal-hal yang buruk ini adalah
bagian dari divisi profesi dan
pengamanan yang merupakan
sistem internal pengawasan di
kepolisian.
Berikutnya kita mesti melihat
bagaimana juga ternyata dari model yang
seperti itu ada ketidakadilan yang jelas
terasa. Misalnya
kasus narkoba.
Kalau kita orang biasa yang melakukan
hukumannya luar biasa berat.
Tapi apa yang terjadi ketika seorang
polisi ditemukan menggunakan narkoba?
Sanksinya adalah salat.
tentu saja sangat-sangat jomplang.
Kemudian juga jangan lupa kasus Avan
Kurniawan pun yang terjadi adalah secara
internal orang yang menyetir mobil itu
diminta untuk meminta maaf. Pidananya
mana?
Bagaimana dengan pengawasan eksternal?
Kalau kita tinggalkan dulu pengawasan
eksternal dari DPR, Ombutsman dan lain
sebagainya, kita fokus pada Kompolnas.
Karena waktu awal didirikan memang
Kopolnas itu menimbulkan harapan. Saya
kira kita semua waktu itu berharap
banyak ya karena kita menganggap ini
kita butuh nih yang eksternal tapi
ternyata desain institusionalnya sangat
jauh dari yang kita harapkan.
Pertama wewenangnya sangat-sangat
terbatas.
Mereka hanya bisa memberikan saran dan
pertimbangan
kepada Presiden dan tidak bisa secara
langsung memberikan sanksi bahkan tidak
terlibat dalam ee investigasi dalam
kasus-kasus yang terjadi di internal.
Kemudian yang kedua dari segi struktur
kita juga bisa lihat bahwa strukturnya
itu bisa dilihat di sini ya katanya
eksternal tapi nyatanya
yang dari perwakilan masyarakat bisa
dibilang minoritas 4 lawan 3 dan
ternyata ketuanya X officio harus
menteri koordinator
yang mengatasi kepolisian. Jadi sekarang
misalnya Menko Polkam, bahkan tiga orang
perwakilan masyarakat pun seringki
biasanya yang cukup dekat dengan
kerja-kerja kepolisian.
Karena itu ee belakangan bahkan ada
pernyataan dari seorang anggota Komonas
yang perwakilan masyarakat yang
terdengar seperti menjadi corong
kepolisian.
Ternyata ada jarak. Jadi dia tidak
ditabrak terus jatuh ya. Dia memang
jatuh dulu. Enggak kelihatan sama kalau
di video ini ya potongannya ini enggak
kelihatan oleh ee sopir tadi oleh
terduga. Setelah itu enggak kelihatan
makanya ya dia bablas gitu.
Di sini kita mesti melihat ulang
sebenarnya
apa yang terjadi dengan tubuh
kepolisian. Tadi kita bicara
pengawasannya dan sekarang kita bicara
masalah kedua, kita bedah kewenangannya.
kepolisian sebenarnya cukup jelas
kewenangannya. Keamanan, ketertiban
masyarakat, menegakkan hukum berhenti di
situ. Sehingga kita boleh punya
pertanyaan lanjutan yang mempertanyakan
kenapa ada urusan-urusan administratif
yang sebenarnya tidak membutuhkan
skill-skill tertentu dalam penegakan
hukum, tapi dilakukan oleh kepolisian
misalnya pengurusan SIM dan STNK.
Jadi, sekedar bercerita misalnya saya
pernah membuat SIM di Amerika Serikat,
saya enggak bawa sekarang karena SIM-nya
sudah habis tahun 2021. Saya belum
perpanjang. Tapi dulu yang memberikan
saya SIM bukan kepolisian di negara
bagian tempat saya belajar
yang memberikan saya SIM itu sebuah unit
di pemerintah daerahnya namanya
Department of Licensing tapi bukan
kepolisian. Jadi saya ikut tes tertulis,
ikut tes menyetir oleh sipil bukan oleh
polisi.
Nah, karena masalah terlalu luasnya
kewenangan ini, akhirnya justru wewenang
yang utama malah tidak terselesaikan
dengan baik. Kita punya datanya di sini.
Misalnya kita bisa lihat tahun 2022
jumlah kejahatan yang diselesaikan
38,1.
2023 48,8.
Kan harusnya semuanya diselesaikan bila
mereka memang fokus. Dan karena ini
kepercayaan masyarakat juga kelihatannya
berkurang ya. Kita bisa lihat dari angka
orang yang melapor ini datanya data dari
statistik kriminalnya BPS.
Orang yang mau melapor ke kepolisian itu
ternyata tidak banyak. Lebih banyak yang
merah. Yang merah yang mendominasi alias
yang tidak mau datang ke polisi.
Makanya saya kira ini kan saya kira kita
semua merasakan ada tagar percuma lapor
polisi satu hari satu oknum.
No viral, no justice. Itu yang kita
alami sehari-hari.
Selain disebabkan kewenangan yang
terlalu banyak, kasus-kasus yang tidak
selesai itu juga seringki disebabkan
karena ada keterkaitan dengan
orang-orang yang bagian dari elit
politik atau bisnis. Jadi bukan sekedar
lemahnya alat bukti misalnya kasus pagar
laut.
Kita semua pasti masih ingat karena
begitu heboh waktu itu beritanya. Dan
justru karena heboh awalnya polisi
benar-benar serius sekali
mentersangkakan
empat orang termasuk seorang kepala desa
di situ. Tapi belakangan ketika ternyata
ditemukan ada orang-orang yang ya nama
besar punya kekuatan ekonomi yang sangat
kuat yang terjadi adalah aparat penegak
hukum kepolisian dan kejaksaan
membolak-balik kasus penanganan kasus.
Jadi sangat-sangat melambat.
Jadi memang sih ada ucapan yang klasik
sekali dari Lord Acton kan. Power tends
to corrupt, absolute power corrups
absolutely. Sebenarnya poinnya dalam
konteks reformasi kepolisian adalah
kewenangan kepolisian harus kita
evaluasi.
[Tepuk tangan]
Kesehariannya itu kita melihat ada
kecenderungan penggunaan
kesewenang-wenangan, abuse of power.
Jadi merasa punya kuasa, merasa punya ee
jabatan, merasa punya seragam dengan
mudah melakukan pelanggaran.
Gampang banget kan polisi bilang Gama
gitu ya dia e melakukan tawuran. Terus
sebelumnya juga Afif juga di Padang juga
disebut melakukan tawuran.
Memohon maaf yang sebesar-besarnya
kepada Bapak Kapolri dan institusi Polri
atas lagu ciptaan kami dengan judul lagu
bayar bayar Bayar.
dan para pendamping yang bekerja, para
advokat ya, para pegiat lingkungan,
pegiat anti korupsi, pegiat demokrasi
ini juga mengalami telan luar biasa.
Pertama kita lihat dulu tugas dan fungsi
kepolisian tadi, ketertiban, keamanan,
penegakan hukum. Nah, kemudian nyatanya
ada jabatan sipil yang memang bisa diisi
oleh polisi. Tadi sudah diuraikan oleh
Mas Bima di chapter pertama. Sekarang
saya ingin menunjukkan
yang besaran-besarannya. Jadi kita bisa
melihat di sini misalnya membandingkan
langsung bahwa yang berwarna merah yaitu
para petinggi kepolisian yang bekerja di
luar PORI itu ternyata lebih banyak
daripada orang-orang atau para perwira
yang bekerja di dalam struktur PORI itu
sendiri yang berwarna biru dan yang di
luar PORI tapi sesuai undang-undang yang
berwarna hijau tetap lebih banyak yang
berwarna merah.
Artinya mereka sesungguhnya ada di semua
hampir semua lini tadi sudah dijelaskan
ada di kehutanan Kementerian Dalam
Negeri sampai dengan Sekretariat
Jenderal Dewan Perwakilan Daerah dan
Dewan Perwakilan Rakyat. Bila argumennya
adalah kemungkinan adanya penegakan
hukum di institusi-institusi tadi, DPR,
DPD, Kementerian Perdagangan dan lain
sebagainya, kan pertanyaannya, jadi apa
gunanya ada sistem penegakan hukum?
Kalau memang ada
sebuah pelanggaran hukum misalnya di
bidang kehutanan,
makanya bisa ada lapor ke polisi. Tidak
perlu polisinya yang masuk di semua
institusi di negara ini. Hal kedua yang
kita harus lihat adalah
mewenang penyidikannya yang spesifik,
penyelidikan dan penyidikan. Tapi mari
kita fokus di penyidikan karena ternyata
ada juga penyidikan yang dilakukan oleh
pejabat pegawai negeri atau penyidik
pegawai negeri sipil atau PPNS di banyak
sekali kementerian lingkungan hidup,
Pertambangan, Perikanan, dan seterusnya.
Kerangka hukumnya ada di Undang-Undang
tentang kitab Undang-Undang Hukum Acara
Pidana yang mengatur mengenai bagaimana
penegakan hukum dilakukan. Di situ
dikatakan
penyidik memang harus polisi, penyelidik
juga polisi. Dan kemudian ada juga yang
namanya PPNS, tapi kemudian diatur juga
bahwa PPNS harus berada di bawah
koordinasi
kepolisian.
Nah, tapi kan pertanyaan kritis yang
sangat boleh kita ajukan adalah
pasti butuh pengetahuan dan skill yang
mumpuni untuk bisa misalnya menyidik
soal-soal yang kaitannya spesifik sekali
soal kehutanan atau pasar modal atau
perbankan. Bayangkan orang-orang yang
berkuliah 4 tahun kalau S1. Tapi
kadang-kadang kan ahli tentu saja ada
yang S2, S3. Bertahun-tahun kuliah harus
disupervisi oleh polisi yang mengalami
pendidikannya di akademi kepolisian yang
tentu saja tidak akan mendalami
perbankan, tidak akan mendalami pasar
modal dan lain sebagainya.
Jadi ini yang membuat akhirnya kita
boleh bertanya-tanya
apakah kita mau penyidikan menjadi
efektif dan juga efisien
dan kemudian jadi ada asumsi polisi bisa
masuk ke banyak persoalan sampai-sampai
pada suatu ketika polisi merasa ketika
ee pasar saham turun naik, polisi hadir
di situ dan ingin ikut memantau harga
saham. seakan-akan pasar, pasar modal,
pelaku pasar kemudian menjadi takut pada
polisi dan tidak akan melakukan
perdagangan di pasar saham.
Jangan-jangan dibayangkan kayak pasar
biasa.
Sepertinya sih begitu. Jangan-jangan itu
juga disebabkan karena
mungkin minimnya pengetahuan tentang apa
itu pasar modal dan bagaimana pasar
modal itu bekerja.
Nah, bila kewenangan penyidikan ini
didesentralisasi
sebenarnya bisa jadi banyak sekali
penyidikan yang bisa efektif. Sebenarnya
kita punya referensi untuk itu, yaitu
KPK sebelum 2019, catat sebelum 2019 ada
penyidik KPK waktu itu yang bisa
melakukan penyidikan secara maksimal.
Dia bisa dalam sekali menggali dan
sangat ee apa? Efektif begitu ya.
Nah, itu catatan soal kewenangan. Tapi
kan kalau bicara kewenangan kemudian
kita juga harus melihat secara
ketatanegaraan sebenarnya kepolisian
letaknya di mana sih? Kenapa
kewenangannya bisa begitu banyak?
Kita bandingkan sedikit dengan
saudaranya yaitu TNI.
Karena saya bilang saudara karena dulu
kan tentu saja namanya ABRI, Angkatan
bersenjata Republik Indonesia. Kemudian
waktu setelah reformasi ada reformasi ee
sektor keamanan mereka dipisah. Waktu
dipisah TNI diletakkan di bawah
Kementerian Pertahanan tapi PORI tetap
langsung di bawah Presiden.
Nah, sebenarnya terlihat bagaimana
akhirnya struktur yang seperti itu
membuat
relasi presiden dengan kepolisian jadi
begitu langsung. Jangan-jangan Uda Feri
yang tadi dibicarakan soal bagaimana
fenomena parcok bisa lahir salah satunya
disumbang oleh pasti banyak ya faktornya
ya tapi disumbang oleh kelangsungan atau
sifat langsungnya relasi antara Presiden
dengan Kapolri.
Nah, ada ee kawan-kawan koalisi
reformasi kepolisian yang sudah
mendaftar masalah-masalah sistemik dalam
PORI itu apa? tidak ada pengawasan
efektif
pendidikan yang salah arah. Kenapa salah
arah? Karena selama ini barangkali
karena baru bercerai setelah ABRI, maka
masih cenderung militeristik dalam
sistem pendidikannya ketimbang skill
untuk menghadapi massa secara damai,
mengelola pertandingan bola seperti di
Kanjuruhan dan lain sebagainya.
Makanya budaya kekerasan terus tumbuh,
organisasi tertutup, SDM tidak adil.
Dalam arti rekrutmen dan promosi itu
banyak sekali dilakukan tanpa
meritokrasi.
Masuk bisnis dan politik,
tebang pilih hukum. Tadi juga sudah kita
uraikan lemah soal HAM. Makanya sudah
banyak perkara mulai dari Kanjuruhan
tadi ee sampai dengan peristiwa
pembunuhan Gama di Semarang dan lain
sebagainya. brutal di lapangan.
Brimok lagi-lagi warisan dari bersatunya
kepolisian dan TNI. Masih ada pasukan
yang namanya Brimop yang kemudian ee
ketika menangani massa di lapangan yang
muncul adalah model-model seperti
dilindasnya Avan Kurniawan pada Agustus
2025 dan wewenang yang tadi terlalu
luas.
komitmen kapori segala macam. Mana
dijalanin enggak tuh? Mana
melindungi terlapor.
Terlapor bayar berapa sih? Hah? Gua jual
ginjal juga nih buat bayar hukum. Gila
kali ya.
Jadi permintaan uang itu sebanyak tiga
kali dilakukan. Yang terakhir itu dia
tidak menyebutkan nominal. Jadi saya
tidak berikan. Tapi dia hanya
menyebutkan kisaran tidak nominal tepat
ya. Kisarannya dua digit.
penyidiknya memeras masyarakat dengan
tanda kutip ya Irwasum dan Popam yang
memeras ke dalam.
Nah, tentu saja prinsipnya semua
kewenangan itu kan satu harus berada di
korider konstitusi. Kedua wajib wajib
sekali dilengkapi dengan kompetensi dan
harus ada pengawasan. Jadi ada lima
langkah paling tidak yang harus
dilakukan.
Pertama, soal police brutality,
brutalitas kepolisian. Kita mesti
bongkar dengan merombak budaya
militerisme dalam pendidikan. Kita bisa
mulai dekati dengan community policing,
tapi jangan disama dengan disamakan
dengan community policing yang tadi
sudah Feri ceritakan ya. Apa tadi? Eing
cooling system. cooling system bukan
seperti itu. Tapi yang lebih ramah
kepada masyarakat termasuk itu tadi
kalau mau mengawasi pertandingan bola
begitu ada sedikit saja keributan jangan
langsung dilempar gas air mata, tapi
bagaimana caranya mengelola dulu massa
dengan baik misalnya bisa juga misalnya
dengan menggunakan katakanlah
body cam. Jadi ada akuntabilitasnya dan
mencegah polish brutality. Yang kedua,
kekuasaan yang berlebihan atau kita
sebut saja overpower itu bisa kita
kurangi, kita bongkar dengan
pertama-tama
kita letakkan dululah kepolisian secara
ketatanegaraan di tempat yang tepat
misalnya di bawah salah satu kementerian
tertentu dan mengurai wewenang di bidang
administrasi yang tadi saya cerita soal
STNK, soal SIM dan seterusnya. Yang
ketiga, pendidikan dan kompetensi juga
harus diperbaiki. Misalnya
dengan memastikan berkurangnya
pendidikan alam militer dan memastikan
justru kompetensi dalam hal lainnya,
penegakan hukum tentu saja dengan
korelasinya dengan aparat penegak hukum
lain. Yang keempat, soal integritas.
Nah, di sini masuk soal-soal ee
transparansi anggaran. ee kemudian juga
transparansi dalam hal
penindakan-penindakan yang mereka
lakukan secara internal. Dan yang
kelima, pengawasan dan impunitas ini
bisa kita perbaiki dengan kita bongkar
model pengawasan yang sekarang sudah
ada. Pastikan Komponas lebih punya
wewenang yang lebih nyata. Tidak hanya
rekomendasi, bahkan sebaiknya Kompolnas
itu juga ikut dalam menginvestigasi
secara internal. Jadi lebih menggigit
begitu. Dan secara internal pun kita
mesti pastikan kalau memang ada pidana
jangan berhenti di etik. Bawa betul ke
pidana sebagaimana halnya orang-orang
lainnya.
Sekarang kita masuk ke bagian yang
kedua, reformasi TNI.
Reformasi TNI tadi saya sudah
sebut-sebut. kita tentu saja punya ABRI
dulu, maka kita akan bisa menelusuri
menelusuri secara sejarah. Dari dulu
memang persoalan TNI ini enggak akan
berhenti di soal pertahanan saja, tapi
kita akan melihat kelindannya dengan
persoalan ekonomi dan persoalan politik.
Sekedar mengingatkan misalnya pada 2008
tuh presidennya masih SBY pernah ada
yang namanya
ee semacam satgas begitu ya untuk
membereskan bisnis militer. Karena
konteksnya waktu itu ada ee baru
reformasi sektor keamanan di awal tahun
2000-an. Kemudian yang disadari paling
kuat adalah banyaknya bisnis militer.
Dan ini yang dicoba diurai waktu itu SBY
sebagai presiden yang datang dari pihak
militer punya etikat baik untuk
membentuk tim ini. Catatannya adalah
ternyata belum selesai dan sekarang
malah kembali lagi. Sekarang tentara
kembali masuk ke proyek pemerintahan
yang berkaitan dengan ekonomi,
bukan pertahanan.
misalnya food estate.
Lebih jauh tadi juga sudah diuraikan
kayaknya di baik oleh Mas Zainal maupun
Uda Feri, Mas Bima juga ee tentara juga
merekrut sipil untuk menjadi seperti
tentara alias ada pasukan paramiliter
yang tadi sudah diuraikan jumlahnya ada
di mana-mana.
ini dikarenakan ada undang-undang 23
2019 tadi bahkan sudah feri menyebutkan
peraturan pemerintahnya tuh tapi mari
kita ingat ada undang-undang tentang
pengelolaan sumber daya nasional di
bidang pertahanan itu yang membuat
Komcat bisa direkrut komponen cadangan
padahal di UUD45 Pasal 30 sudah jelas
TNI adalah
alat negara yang bertugas
mempertahankan, melindungi, memelihara
keutuhan dan kedulutan negara.
Mari kita fokus pada alat negara.
TNI itu sebagai alat negara tidak boleh
mengambil keputusan politik dan ia alat
negara dalam arti dia menjalankan fungsi
pertahanan untuk membela warga dan tanah
air Indonesia.
Baik, sekarang kita lihat catatan
penting dari seorang tentara yang juga
seorang pemikir yang bisa memberikan
masukan kepada kita.
Bagaimanapun juga
peran dan kewenangan TNI tidak berubah
karena sudah dikunci di dalam konstitusi
yaitu pertahanan nasional. Itu saja yang
dipegang oleh ee TNI. ee betapun nanti
ee ee kebijakan umum akan diturunkan ee
dari ee otoritas politik ee presiden. Ee
nah ee kebijakan umum itu nanti bisa
misalnya oke TNI harus bisa menyerang
musuh sebelum musuh menyerang kita atau
bisa juga kebijakan umum TNI cukup
bertahan saja di batas wilayah nasional.
Itu adalah keputusan politik. Setelah
itu dijabarkan ee oleh ee TNI.
Jadi kembalikan
TNI adalah alat negara. Dia tidak
mengambil keputusan politik tidak
seharusnya. maka dia tidak boleh
sebenarnya tentara aktif kalau sudah
pensiun kita bisa perdebatkan lagi. Tapi
tentara aktif tidak boleh masuk dalam
pemerintahan dan juga bahkan selanjutnya
reformasi militer juga harus
menghentikan rekrutmen komponen cadangan
yang menjadikan lebih banyak kekuatan
militer di lapangan.
Demokrasi tidak membutuhkan militer di
semua aspek kehidupan bernegara.
serahkan semua pada ahlinya, gizi kepada
ahli gizi, bercocok tanam kepada para
petani dan ahli pertanian.
Nah, bicara soal
urusan-urusan yang berkaitan dengan ee
misalnya
pertanian, tambang, dan lain sebagainya,
kita bisa kembali kepada yayasan yang
terafiliasi militer yang berkembang
subur sekali di era Orde Baru dan
sekarang hidup lagi.
Jadi kita lihat di sini misalnya tentu
saja sesuai angkatannya ada Yayasan Adi
Upaya, ada Yayasan Bumi AL dan Yayasan
Kartika Ekapaksi. Kita perhatikan
jenis-jenis
ee
tindakan atau kegiatan ekonomi yang
mereka tangani. Yayasan Adi Upaya
misalnya ternyata tidak hanya berurusan
dengan hal-hal yang berkaitan dengan
angkatan udara, tapi juga alat kesehatan
dan farmasi, perkebunan sawit misalnya.
Yayasan Bumi AL
mengurusi juga agrobisnis, kemudian
logistik dan transportasi laut. Okelah
masih sedikit terkait tapi juga kita
harus melihat soal perdagangan umum dan
lain sebagainya. Belum lagi Yayasan
Kartika Ekapaksi yang lagi-lagi juga
agribisnis sawit masuk di situ. Logging
dan kehutanan itu juga sangat menarik
untuk kita lihat konstruksi jalan-bisnis
sampai perkebunan minyak atsiri.
Nah, situasi berikutnya adalah dengan
model seperti itu juga banyak
purnawirawan jenderal yang menjadi
petinggi Badan Gizi Nasional. Ini
konteksnya masih pada bagaimana tentara
akhirnya masuk di banyak ee lini usaha
maupun hal-hal yang kaitannya dengan
kemasyarakatan yang di luar bidang
pertahanan.
Di sini kita bisa lihat
yang warna hijau yang ternyata dominan.
Ternyata orang-orang yang mengurusi gizi
adalah para purnawirawan jenderal.
Mungkin ada yang akan berargumen, "Tapi
kan mereka purnawirawan berarti tidak
melanggar hukum." Nah, tapi di titik ini
kita harus melihat
bagaimana akhirnya satu kompetensi.
Apakah persoalan gizi bisa ditangani?
Ini petingginya ya, bisa ditangani oleh
orang-orang yang selama ini belajarnya
tentang peperangan. Kemudian yang kedua
kita mesti lihat dalamnya karena kita
akan temukan juga situasi di mana
ternyata 452
dapur
program makan bergizi gratis itu
dikuasai oleh TNI. Dan secara spesifik
kita bisa melihat lagi dari petanya.
Dari petanya ini kita akan bisa melihat
secara langsung bagaimana
qodam-kodam
itu ternyata dikerahkan untuk mengelola
dapur-dapur makan bergizi gratis ini.
Bahkan kita mesti lihat lebih detail
siapa yang mengerjakan proyek makan
bergizi gratis ini. Nah, tadi sudah
sedikit ada spill deta ya dari Mas Bima.
Jadi saya kira ini saatnya kita mengurai
karena akan menarik sekali kita melihat
ccle politik dan kekuasaan yang ada di
pengerjaan proyek MBG ini. Mas Bima
silakan.
Lu lagi Bim.
Yo.
Hajar Bim.
Wah. kerjaan yang lumayan menarik karena
tadi sesuai dengan yang Mbak Bifitri
bilang bahwa di chapter 1 tadi kita
spill sedikit hubungan ccle politik
terutama militer terkait dengan makan
bergizi gratis. Tapi kita coba lihat
lebih dalam lagi. Jadi kami tuh
menemukan surat edaran dari PPATK nomor
7 tahun 2025. Ini sebenarnya PPATK ingin
menghimbau kepada bank umum bahwa tolong
mereka yang memiliki proyek makan
bergizi gratis atau pengelola
dapur-dapur MBG itu harus dilihat
indikator transaksi keuangan yang
mencurigakan. Nah, ini kita sudah
mengkonfirmasi juga ke Ketua PPATK bahwa
memang benar surat edaran ini. He.
Jadi sudah dicross check ya,
sudah dicross check, sudah dikonfirmasi.
Tetapi kita juga melihat bahwa di dalam
surat edaran ini ternyata ada 15 yayasan
yang dikecualikan
dari identifikasi transaksi keuangan
atau profiling transaksi keuangan yang
mencurigakan. Nah, ini juga sudah
dikonfirmasi juga memang betul di dalam
surat edaran ada 15 yayasan ini.
Tentu nama-namanya tadi yang disebutkan
oleh Mbak Bifitri ini sebagian
terkonfirmasi juga. Ada beberapa
nama-nama yayasan yang cukup menarik.
Nah, kita ambil salah satu contoh ya,
yayasan kita googling yang namanya
adalah Yayasan Purnawira
Wan Pejuang Indonesia Raya atau PPIR.
Begitu kita masuk ke dalam website-nya
ini jelas
bahwa ada foto Prabowo Subianto sebagai
ketua dewan pembina Purnawirawan. dan
kita gali lebih dalam dan kita baca nih
anggaran dasarnya itu di pasal 1 itu
dijelaskan bahwa memang purnawirawan
pejuang Indonesia Raya merupakan sayap
partai gerindra. Nah, jadi dari sini
kemudian kita lihat lagi dalam list
yayasan yang dikecualikan dari PPATK
tadi
itu juga ada nama Yayasan Adi Upaya.
Tadi sudah sedikit Mbak Abif Fitri
jelaskan, tapi yang menarik adalah
sebagai yayasan ini dia mengelola dapur
MBG. Begitu kita cek Yayasan Adi Upaya
ini memang terkait dengan angkatan
udara.
Heeh.
Jadi jelas nih ada kaitan antara
beberapa yayasan milik TNI itu dalam
dapur umum MBG.
Tapi tidak berhenti. Ini bukan cuman
soal hijau saja, tapi ada kepolisian
yang kita lihat itu melalui Yayasan
Bayangkari. Nah,
ini istri-istri polisi nih ya. Yayasan
Bayangkari ini ya.
Yayasan Bayangkari istrinya polisi. Jadi
Yayasan Kemala Bayangkari ini ketua
pembinanya cukup dekat sangat dekat
dengan Kapolri yang saat ini ada. Ya,
jadi ini saya kembalikan lagi kepada
Mbak Bib untuk melanjutkan analisisnya.
Ya, tadi di makan bergizi gratis, tapi
ternyata kita enggak bisa berhenti di
situ. Kita harus kulik lagi di sektor
berikutnya yaitu tambang.
Ini sebuah sektor yang sangat sering
kita bahas, masalahnya banyak dan kita
akan menemukan banyaknya para jenderal
di pusaran tambang ini. Bisa dilihat di
sini ya eh perusahaan-perusahaannya
Antam, Tobabara dan seterusnya.
Barangkali akan ada yang bilang, "Oh,
tapi kan pernawirawan semua nih."
Betul. Tapi kan begini, kita mesti
melihat militer itu sebagai sebuah
organisasi komando yang disiplinnya kuat
sekali. Kalaupun secara formal
jenderal-jenderal yang sudah
purnawirawan itu bisa menduduki jabatan
yang seperti ini, tidak melanggar
undang-undang secara ketat. Kalau kita
analisisnya ketat melihat pasal dalam
undang-undang, tapi bisa jadi
keterlibatan para purnawirawan jenderal
ini membuka peluang adanya pengamanan
bisnis ya karena komandonya masih
tersisa. Tentu saja
masalah lainnya adalah misalnya juga
transparansi anggaran.
Banyak sekali pertanyaan muncul tentang
pengadaan alat utama sistem
persenjataan.
Auditnya dipertanyakan ini belinya
bagaimana? Apa kok kok kok kelihatannya
lebih mahal? Karena zaman sekarang
apalagi kita dengan mudah bisa mengecek
harga-harga secara online. Dan
pertanyaan-pertanyaan ini semua muncul
karena selama ini anggaran militer itu
diperlakukan sebagai rahasia negara.
Misalnya kita lihat di sini
undang-undang tentang keterbukaan
informasi publik yang memang
mengecualikan
pas ee anggaran atau informasi yang
terkait dengan pertahanan dan keamanan
negara. Tapi kalau kita mau lebih dalam
melihatnya kan sebenarnya ada
bagian-bagian penting yang bisa dibuka
kepada publik tanpa membocorkan strategi
militer.
Transparansi akan meminimalkan
penyalahgunaan. itu selalu kuncinya.
Nah, ada satu lagi nih, satu lagi yang
juga sama pentingnya dan akan banyak
berpengaruh pada semua yang sudah kita
uraikan yaitu soal peradilan militer.
Kenapa penting?
Karena jangan lupa
segala macam pelanggaran hukum tindak
pidana yang mungkin dilakukan dalam
tugas tugas mulai dari persoalan bisnis
kemudian misalnya mengerjakan
proyek-proyek pemerintah
kan pada akhirnya harus ditangani secara
hukum secara adil.
Jadi kita juga mesti melihat bahwa
bagaimana mungkin orang-orang yang kerja
di bidang-bidang nonmiliter
tadi ya seperti perdagangan, mengambil
keputusan politik dan lain sebagainya.
Begitu mereka melakukan tindak pidana
mereka ingin diistimewakan.
Masalahnya memang di UD45 karena UD45
itu menempatkan peradilan militer
bersisian dengan peradilan umum untuk
perdata dan pidana. peradilan tata usaha
negara dan peradilan agama. Nah, kan
harusnya
wilayah peradilan itu dibagi berdasarkan
tindak atau tindakannya apa, bukan
berdasarkan orangnya siapa kan. Equality
before the law.
Nah, jadi kalau ada pengistimewaan
karena peradal militer itu artinya kan
mulai dari penyidiknya, penuntutnya,
hakimnya itu semua dari militer. Nah,
sekarang bayangkan kalau ada militer
yang melakukan tindak pidana tapi
kemudian tidak mau diadili di peradilan
umum. Misalnya Tipikor, kita punya
catatan ini pusaran korupsi di TNI mulai
dari kasus Basarnas, kemudian juga kasus
ee BPTWP, kasus Bakamla dan kita akan
lihat ternyata em betul tetap ada vonis
dan lain sebagainya, tapi tetap saja ada
pengistimewaan
karena pada akhirnya semua bagian dari
peradilan militer dari militer
sampai-sampai penegak hukum pada satu
titik perlu minta maaf pada militer
kedar karena mereka menjalankan tugasnya
sebagai penegak hukum.
Padahal waktu itu Fitri waktu itu ya.
Kenapa waktu itu kan
mungkin ada kekhilafan,
ada kelupaan
bahwasanya manakala ada melibatkan TNI
harus diserahkan kepada
TNI.
Bukan kita yang tangani, bukan KPK.
Seperti kata Mas Uceng, bukannya Idul
Fitri tapi sudah minta maaf. Sekedar
karena mereka menjalankan tugasnya untuk
melakukan penegakan hukum.
Nah, jadi begini. Dalam negara demokrasi
memang militer berperan penting dalam
pertahanan, tapi justru karena itu
mereka hanya boleh masuk ke ruang-ruang
yang bukan pertahanan
ee atau mereka tidak boleh masuk ke
dalam ruang-ruang yang bukan pertahanan
karena dua alasan. Pertama, militer
dilatih untuk berperang.
Jadi, dia tidak ada kultur yang
deliberatif gitu. kita berdebat dulu tuh
enggak bisa
karena mereka harus taat komando kan
mereka dilatih untuk berperang. Kalau
mereka berunding dulu, eh kita kita
defens enggak ya? Kita defense enggak ya
kalahlah Indonesia. Mereka memang harus
profesional dengan cara mereka nurut
pada komando dari atas. Tapi itu yang
tidak kompatibel dengan demokrasi.
Akibatnya seperti yang sekarang ini saya
kira sudah sering kita lihat, yang
terjadi adalah politik komando, ekonomi
komando tidak terlalu mengurusi kritik
yang ada di luar sana. Dan kedua ini
juga sangat penting, militer
pegang senjata. Kira-kira sederhananya
begitu. Menguai persenjataan dan
strategi perang yang basisnya adalah
kekerasan.
Nah, jadi interaksinya kalau mereka
berbisnis interaksi dengan kelompok
bisnis lain atau ketemu dengan
masyarakat sipil, ada relasi yang tidak
seimbang dan kecenderungannya adalah
pendekatannya kekerasan juga. Nah, jadi
perombakan apa yang mesti dilakukan?
Paling tidak ada
empat hal yang mesti kita lakukan.
Pertama, kita mesti kembalikan TNI ke
fungsi konstitusionalnya
di bidang pertahanan.
Tidak perlu ada lagi pemaknaan lebih
jauh pertahanan itu apa sampai ke
ketahanan pangan misalnya. Sama-sama ada
kata tahan tapi tentunya sangat berbeda.
Pertahanan itu untuk melindungi tanah
air kita. Kedua, TNI juga tidak boleh
masuk dalam dunia bisnis, termasuk jasa
pengamanan. Karena TNI tugasnya
mempertahankan negara ini. Yang ketiga,
transparansi anggaran militer sampai
batas-batas yang tidak membahayakan
strategi pertahanan.
Yang keempat, pengadilan militer itu
hanya untuk tindak pidana militer, bukan
untuk personel militer.
Nah, itu untuk TNI. Sekarang kita harus
masuk kepada
bagian yang ketiga, yaitu perombakan
sistem politik. Nah, di sini
jadi kita kan tadi sudah melihat ya
bagaimana elemen otak itu atau kerusakan
produksi hukum dan kebijakan yang sudah
diuraikan di bagian sebelumnya.
Sehingga sekarang kita harus melihat
kembali bagaimana hukum dan kebijakan
itu dibuat dan oleh siapa dan
orang-orang yang membuat itu gimana
dipilihnya sampai kita melihat apa yang
terjadi pada hari ini. Kita makanya
harus melakukan perombakan sistem
politik.
Kalau kita melihat dunia politik kita
nih, kita punya yang baru dan yang lama.
Old and new. Partai baru, partai lama,
tapi perilakunya sama. Kita punya
misalnya Partai Demokrasi Indonesia
Perjuangan
yang ketua umumnya sudah jadi ketua umum
sudah 32 tahun sejak tahun 93.
Tapi kita memang punya yang new, yang
baru, PSI, ketua umumnya sangat kontras.
baru jadi anggota 2 hari dia langsung
bisa jadi ketua umum.
Jalur kilat ya, Pak.
Jadi apa nih yang kita lihat? Kita
melihat elit partai ini kan sebenarnya
elit yang satu bertahan seperti ini,
yang satu begitu cepat dikarbit dia
naik. Tentu saja kita tahu kayak
sangarap adalah anak mantan Presiden
Joko Widodo.
Tapi kita fokus di elit politiknya.
Jadi, parpol itu memang didominasi oleh
sekelompok elit dan tidak terlalu peduli
dengan urusan mewakili.
Kita lihat dulu dari data ini. Jadi,
penentuan calon anggota legislatif DPR
dan DPRD yang dilakukan oleh partai itu
dari penelitian yang dilakukan hampir
60% calek calon legislatif di DPR itu
ternyata tidak ada kaitannya dengan
daerah pemilihan yang mereka wakili.
Bisa dilihat di sini ada yang ee
36,4%-nya
tidak tinggal dan tidak lahir di dapil
itu. I
bahkan sampai 57,5%
enggak tinggal di dapil itu. Jadi kalau
Anda adalah orang katakanlah orang NTT,
nanti kita akan lihat siapa yang
mewakili NTT pada suatu ketika ternyata
bukan orang NTT. Nah, saya tampilkan di
sini data LDBank Kompas dalam konteks
pencalekan
karena saya ingin menyoroti bagaimana
Parpol memilih calon-calon
yang calon-calon orang-orang yang akan
mewakili kita. Yang memilihkan adalah
partai.
Nah, kita bisa lihat beberapa sampelnya.
Misalnya di sini kita punya satu nama
yang saya kira banyak orang yang
familiar, Mutya Hafid.
Dia dapilnya dia tiga kali terpilih.
Dapilnya adalah Kota Medan dan
seterusnya di Sumatera Utara.
Lihat, ia berdomisili di Jakarta Timur,
lahirnya di Bandung dan tidak pernah
tinggal di dapilnya. bahkan sampai
sempat sekolah di luar negeri.
Satu lagi tentu saja juga sangat
terkenal sudah keluar dari penjara
orangnya
namanya Setia Novanto. Tadi saya
sebut-sebut yang dari NTT
pasti juga barangkali agak kesal ya
melihatnya ya. Bagaimana ternyata
wakilnya di DPR ternyata bukan orang
sana sama sekali. Bukan bukan hanya
domisilinya tapi dia bukan lahir di
sana. enggak pernah tinggal di sana sama
sekali. Enggak relate dengan soal-soal
yang terjadi di NTT. Satu lagi yang juga
tidak yang juga tidak asing lagi adalah
Tommy Soeharto. Ya, tidak lolos sih,
tapi kan polanya terbaca dan yang
kontras adalah dia dicalonkan dari dapil
Papua.
Dan kita tahu persis sebagai anak dari
penguasa Orde Baru, dia sama sekali
tidak ada urusan dengan Papua. Bahkan,
oh jangan lupa ia juga pernah dipenjara
karena membunuh hakim agung ya, tapi
bisa menjadi calek dan memiliki sebuah
partai politik.
Nah, jadi memang buat partai politik
seringki ini bukan soal mewakili secara
substantif.
Kecenderungannya parpol hanya berfokus
pada meraih suara sebanyak-banyaknya,
bukan soal kompetensi, bukan soal
relevansi. Karena toh yang akan
menentukan keputusan politik adalah
elite parpol. Karena itu kebanyakan
parpol juga akan mencari pendulang suara
atau votter seperti selebritis
yang kemarin-kemarin juga banyak menjadi
pertanyaan buat kita, kok mereka bisa
terpilih? Ya, karena itu tadi partai
tidak peduli dengan kompetensi mereka.
Nah, tapi ada juga yang kecenderungan
yang ketiga untuk menggambarkan perilaku
parpol. Parpol juga akan cenderung
memilih orang yang berduit. Nah, jadi
kalau butuh melakukan politik uang,
silakan rogoh kocek masing-masing.
Bahkan parpolnya mungkin akan meminta
bagian dari uang orang-orang kaya itu
untuk menjalankan parpolnya.
Ada lagi sih kecenderungan yang yang
berikutnya tadi saya sudah ketiga ya
berarti ini keempat dia dipilih dari
keluarga elit politik.
Bisa dilihat di sini anak dan cucu ketua
umum PDI Perjuangan nyalek
anak dari ketua umum Partai Nasdem,
keluarga penuh dari Partai Perindo, juga
ketua umum PAN. Jadi kecenderungan ini
ada sangat luas. Jadi, parpol memang
tidak didesain sebagai partai kader.
Jadi, partai umumnya tidak punya akar.
Saya yakin
Anda kebanyakan tidak kenal dengan orang
yang mewakili Anda di DPR.
Begitu berkuasanya elit parpol sampai
mereka menyalahgunakan mekanisme PW
penggantian antar waktu yang konsep
awalnya harusnya dilakukan oleh kita kan
kita yang diwakili sering disebut
recalling system. Tapi di Indonesia ini
sepenuhnya wewenang dari partai politik.
Jadi sering disalahgunakan, datanya ada
dan penyalahgunaan ini seringki
dilakukan
untuk memastikan orang-orang yang sudah
disaring dan nanti kadang-kadang
ganti-gantian loh, kadang-kadang
ganti-gantian itu ee bisa mendapatkan
jabatan di DPR atau DPRD.
Dan kadang-kadang PWI ini bahkan
dilakukan sebelum mereka menjabat.
sebagai contoh atau sebelum mereka
dilantik begitu ya istilah hukumnya ya.
Misalnya mungkin ada tekanan ada Victor
La Kodat di NTT yang eh sebenarnya bukan
yang terpilih yang paling atas tapi Cek
berikutnya kemudian mengundurkan diri
katanya dengan sukarela
tahu tidak bisa diverifikasi lebih jauh
karena itu keputusan pribadi. atau
seorang yang juga cukup kontroversial e
pada pada tahun-tahun lalu, Arteria
Dahlan yang memberi jalan pada trah
Soekarno
itu. Itu sampelnya dari beberapa yang
terjadi. Nah, akibat dari kekacauan
penentuan wakil rakyat oleh parpol,
komposisi wakil rakyat hanya
mencerminkan apa yang diinginkan oleh
parpol. Jadi itu biasanya tuh pertama
anggota DPR sekarang kebanyakan diisi
oleh pebisnis.
Data dari ICW ini menunjukkan seluruh
partai politik di DPR punya anggota yang
ee juga berstatus sebagai pebisnis. Di
data berikutnya ini kita bisa lihat
semuanya jadinya ya semuanya punya
bagian dari ee atau punya anggota yang
politisi pebisnis. Kira-kira begitu
istilahnya. Rata.
Kita tidak anti orang bisnis ya, tapi
masalahnya adalah benturan kepentingan.
Kasus paling gamblang itu terjadi
misalnya di PDIP. benturan kepentingan
itu kata kuncinya bukan like and
dislike. Misalnya di sini ada salah
seorang kader PDIP namanya Santi Aida
Natalia yang terpilih ditempatkannya di
Komisi 12 dan Komisi 12 ini wewenangnya
memonitor isu tambang lingkungan dan
investasi.
Kita cek ternyata Santi adalah pemilik
salah satu ee perusahaan yang memiliki
IUP tambang nikel, izin usaha
pertambangan nikel di Pulau UGB Maluku
Utara. Namanya bahkan pernah
disebut-sebut terseret kasus korupsi
gubernur Maluku Utara Abdul Ghani
Kasuba. Benturan kepentingan. Masalah
kedua, dunia politik juga dipenuhi oleh
dinasti politik. Kita lihat lagi
sumbernya masih ICW. Ternyata banyak
sekali
anggota DPR yang terhubung dengan
dinasti politik. Jangan melihat
perbandingannya, "Oh, masih ada 48. Oh,
enggak. Harusnya ini enggak ada." Ini
yang mesti kita kritik.
Dan mari kita lihat data berikutnya soal
jumlah kandidat dinasti di Pilkada.
Kalau tadi DPR, yang sekarang Pilkada.
Kita juga bisa lihat datanya di sini ee
kami ambil dari kajian IOS Kenawas dan
Amalinda Safirani. Ternyata tinggi
sekali di Pilkada yang lalu. Lihat
lonjakannya.
Nampaknya kuat dugaannya. Ingat Pilkada
2024 terjadi setelah Pilpres yang
sangat menginspirasi saya kira dengan
nepotisme yang luar biasa antara Joko
Widodo dengan anaknya yang sekarang
menjadi wakil presiden dan dibahas di
film Dirty Food 1. Jadi masalah-masalah
di DPR memang akarnya itu di parpol.
Bagaimana mungkin parpol yang harusnya
mempraktikkan
demokrasi di level negara secara
internal justru mereka tidak demokratis?
Nah, jadi ini ditandai secara internal
parpol ya. Pertama dengan ketua umum
parpol yang kebanyakan dipilih secara
aklamasi.
Kedua, pola pemilihan pengurus inti juga
biasanya menggambarkan hubungan-hubungan
keluarga dan kekerabatan. seringki juga
menggambarkan kedekatan dengan oligarki
lokal maupun nasional. Kan itulah
poinnya dengan oligarki mereka. Jadi
bisa memiliki dalam tanda kutip partai.
Dengan pola rekrutmen seperti ini muncul
yang namanya kartel politik. Kartel
politik itu istilah akademik tentang
persekongkolan antar parpol di DPR yang
memang tugasnya membuat undang-undang.
Jadi kartel inilah yang akan menjadi
pintu masuk utama yang nyaman sekali
bagi pebisnis besar untuk menentukan
kebijakan negara ini. Itu yang dinamakan
oligarki.
[Tepuk tangan]
ke kiri
putarlah ke kiri ke kiri ke kiri ke kiri
dan ke kiri ke kiri ke kiri ke kiri
manis
[Musik]
sekarang kan
manislah kalan kalan kekalan kalan dan
kekalan kekalan
Jadi kartel politik ini yang juga
menyokong weaponization of law. Tadi
sudah dibahas juga oleh ee Mas Zainal
kalau saya tidak salah. Ini menggunakan
hukum sebagai alat berkuasa. Ini yang
kita namakan otak-atik otak otak.
Otak-atik otak. Misalnya dengan membuat
Undang-Undang TNI dan Undang-Undang
BUMN. dua undang-undang yang menyokong
otot politik dan ongkos yang tadi kita
bahas. Tapi tidak hanya dua
undang-undang itu. Kita akan ketemu
banyak. Sebagian tadi sudah dibahas,
kenapa bisa ada kabinet yang demikian
besar? Undang-undang Kementerian
Negaranya sudah diubah duluan. Belum
lagi Pilkada, Cipta Kerja, Minerba, dan
juga pembunuhan KPK pada 2019 yang
dilakukan mengenai melalui perubahan
undang-undang.
Bahkan penggunaan DPR sebagai
seharusnya kan lembaga demokratik ya,
tapi digunakan untuk tujuan nonemokratik
itu tidak hanya di level pembuatan
undang-undang, tapi bahkan mereka ingin
menancapkan pengaruh di lembaga-lembaga
penegakan hukum. Misalnya kita bisa
lihat di video ini,
Bapak jangan lupa
bahwa Bapak dipilih itu dari DPR. Jangan
kembali menghantem DPR, Pak. Ini kan
setelah duduk lupa saya ini berasal dari
DPR.
Konteksnya calon hakim Mahkamah
Konstitusi
ada sedikit kegusaran karena beberapa
undang-undang itu dibatalkan oleh
Mahkamah Konstitusi. Padahal kan kita
membicarakan dalam demokrasi, dalam
negara hukum harus ada checks and
balances. Kalau memang tidak betul
undang-undangnya ya harus dicek oleh
Mahkamah Konstitusi. Tapi ini sudah
dititipkan duluan supaya tidak
ee tidak ada pembatalan undang-undang
yang dilakukan oleh hakim.
Nah, masalahnya begini nih. Sudahlah
tidak nyambung ya kan antara wakil
rakyat dengan rakyatnya.
Pengambilan keputusan di DPR itu pun
sebenarnya berdasarkan fraksi.
Jadi salah tuh kalau ada asumsi ini one
person one vote nih kita pilih orang
yang hebat dia akan menjadi dewa
penolong kita. Tidak akan terjadi.
Karena pengambilan keputusan dilakukan
oleh fraksi. Fraksi adalah tempat
berkumpulnya anggota-anggota DPR dari
sekarang ini ya partai politik yang
sama. Walaupun sebenarnya bisa aja
dilakukan sepanjang ada kesepakatan dari
beberapa partai politik, tapi saat ini
Mas satu fraksi, satu partai politik.
Nah, mereka sebenarnya mengambil
keputusan. Biasanya yang terjadi di DPR
dalam rapat paripurna yang mengambil
keputusan adalah seperti ini. Pandangan
umum fraksi diserahkan kepada pimpinan
sidang.
Tidak boleh lagi ada perbedaan pendapat.
Ketok Palu itu yang terjadi.
Nah, ada satu riset yang menarik sekali
pada 2016 yang dilakukan oleh KPK dan
Brin
tentang bagaimana seharusnya
pola rekrutmen dan kaderisasi yang
ideal.
Dan salah satu masukan yang
sangat-sangat penting dan harus menurut
saya kita ambil konsepnya adalah
harusnya ketika menentukan calon-calon
wakil rakyat yang menjadi ukuran adalah
berapa lama orang itu sudah menjadi
kader profesinya apa saja terserah dia
mau artis mau selebritis atau apapun
asal dia sudah punya kompetensi politik
yang dia dapat dari menjadi kader. Nah,
ini ee satu rekomendasi yang sangat
menarik. Soal berikutnya tadi baru yang
pertama tuh soal kaderisasi. Soal
berikutnya adalah pendanaan partai
politik.
Nah, tahun 2024 misalnya BPK menemukan
sejumlah permasalahan dalam penggunaan
bantuan partai politik.
Bayangkan bantuan yang didapat dari
hibah yang sifatnya formal dari negara
saja ternyata dikelolanya tidak
profesional. Makanya ada masalah.
Bayangkan nyatanya Parpol juga banyak
mendapatkan dana di bawah tangan.
Nah, soal pendanaan parpol ini
sebenarnya yang akan benar-benar
menyuburkan politik uang dan masuknya
oligarki saat ini. Jadi memang benar ada
pendanaan parpol dari APBN per jumlah
kursi. Nah, pemberian dana ini harusnya
lagi ada perbincangan mau dinaikkan dan
seterusnya. apapun nanti yang akan
dihasilkan dan tidak ada masalah dengan
pendanaan dari negara asal
pengawasannya juga sangat kuat bisa
diaudit dan bisa diberikan sanksi
apabila tidak memenuhi syarat. Karena
masuknya dana dari pengusaha tanpa
kontrol itu memang benar-benar jadi
pintu masuk bagi oligarki. Pada awalnya
adalah sumbangan dana kampanye atau dana
partai politik. Namun seperti
diungkapkan dalam banyak riset, pasti
ada pamrih bagi penyumbang pada saat si
penerima dana itu atau penerima
sumbangan menduduki jabatan politik.
Sementara kan sistem pengambilan
keputusan juga ternyata tidak transparan
dan didominasi elit politik. Nah, ini
yang kacau lingkaran setannya lagi nih
yang kita harus putus. Untuk itu dalam
hal pendanaan politik setidaknya ada
empat hal yang harus dilakukan.
Pertama, tentu saja kuatkan sumber dana
dari anggota parpol sembari memperbaiki
demokrasi internalnya. Jadi, kita mau
membangun infrastruktur partai politik
yang jauh lebih baik daripada sekarang.
Ini akan berguna untuk membangun budaya
politik kita juga. Yang kedua, terapkan
dengan ketat pembatasan jumlah
sumbangan.
Sekarang ada, makanya kami tulis di sini
terapkan, batasi.
ini yang tidak pernah di ee apa
ditindaklanjuti dengan baik. Kemudian
terapkan dengan ketat sistem audit
pendanaan parpol
dan juga dana kampanye.
Tegas.
Audit ada tapi sekarang tidak tegas.
Dan tentu saja terapkan dengan ketat
transparansi dana parpol dan juga dana
kampanye.
Di sini kita bicara soal parpol atau
sebuah sistem kepartaian yang sekarang
tengah berjalan.
Kitaatul video ini
[Musik]
ini adalah cerita dari negeri jiran dari
Thailand, Move Forward Party. Kenapa
film ini kami angkat? Karena bukankah
dari semua persoalan yang dari tadi kita
bicarakan, kita jadi berpikir
jangan-jangan kita perlu partai baru.
Karena ini yang terjadi juga di
Thailand. Banyak anak muda pada parpol
yang ada sekarang juga di Indonesia
yang sebenarnya mungkin ingin berbuat
banyak tapi terhalang oleh elit
politiknya. atau banyak juga aktivis
muda yang punya ideal-ideal yang luar
biasa. Tapi kemudian ketika dia masuk ke
partai politik yang ada, dia juga
hapus apa terhapus idealismenya,
terkooptasi karena demokrasi internal
partai tidak berjalan. Jadi seakan-akan
terputus antara cita-cita ideal tentang
politik. Indonesia harus seperti apa, ke
depannya harus bagaimana kita berbangsa
dan seterusnya. seakan-akan terputus
dengan sistem politik.
Sehingga kita bertanya-tanya, gimana
kalau kita bikin partai baru yang
organik, bukan yang dirop dari atas.
Nah, masalahnya saat ini sangat-sangat
sulit untuk mendirikan partai politik.
Saat ini orang-orang yang ingin
mendirikan partai baru akan sangat
terhalang oleh ketentuan yang sangat
administratif dalam Undang-Undang Partai
Politik. misalnya partai itu harus
nasional, harus ada di semua provinsi.
Di tiap provinsi harus ada di minimal
75% kabupaten, kota dan seterusnya.
Kemudian harus ada sekian kantor, ada
verifikasinya, harus bukti sewa,
kantornya benar-benar harus ada. ada
ribuan matra yang harus dibeli. Sehingga
ada yang pernah menghitung bahwa
ternyata dengan ee materai yang ada
sekarang bisa-bisa hanya untuk biaya
materai R70 juta yang keluar dan
seterusnya yang begitu merepotkan
sehingga akhirnya orang yang ingin
mendirikan partai tidak fokus pada
membangun demokrasi internalnya sendiri.
Jadi harusnya ada pembangunan struktur
secara bertahap mulai dari tingkat
daerah atau provinsi sebelum nasional.
Jadi keribetannya barangkali akan kita
dapat lebih jauh dari wawancara berikut
ini.
Ya, bukan hanya mahal, enggak masuk
akal. Dan Anda boleh cek gitu
wawancaranya e Prof. Mahfud gitu ya.
Enggak ada yang lolos di 2024 itu untuk
ikut peserta jadi pemilu. Bayangkan
seper1000 jumlah penduduk. Sekarang 200
berapa? R80 juta penduduk per 1000
berarti 280.000
dia anggota harus ada. Lalu kalau mau
ngomong soal kepengurusan, pengurusan 38
* 30 itu untuk di awal. Bagaimana bisa
di tahap pertama itu ketika kita
mendirikan 30 ee orang pendiri dikali 38
provinsi itu tidak kemudian langsung
jadi badan hukum? Enggak. Jadi di tahap
pertama yang sudah ada notaris gitu pun
itu enggak enggak kemudian jadi badan
hukum ini kan beda banget. Lalu yang
kedua pembentukan kepengurusan dan
sekretariat. Nah, berarti kan tadi 30 *
38 itu baru pendiri. Nah, kalau misalnya
kita pakai logi kita tadi 38 pengurus
terus kalau kabupaten kotanya 514 ee
pengurus kabupaten kota ya 7.300
7.288
kecamatan gitu. Hasilnya itu totalnya
itu kita butuh 12.204.
Karena apa? Karena 4.68
* 3. Tapi dari situ kita bisa ngitung
karena masing-masing harus ada materai.
Kali aja tuh 12.204 dikali materai
Rp10.000 berarti udah Rp12.40.000
gitu kan. Itu baru materainya aja. biaya
materainya 644
juta untuk nyewa 3.606
sekretariat ee 12 bulan atau setahun 1
bulannya R2 juta kan. Tapi kan kalau
untuk Jakarta, Surabaya mana ada.
Kayaknya wawancaranya panjang sekali ya.
Kita sudah mulai pusing juga. Mungkin
yang relate dengan ini Mas Bima aja kali
ya. Ini orang-orang hukum nih biasanya
agak susah kalau hitung-hitungan
karena luar biasa
rumit dan penuh hitung-hitungan. Yang
tak mengherankan karena itu kalaupun ada
partai baru, partai barunya itu
kecenderungannya adalah pecahan dari
partai lama atau disokong oleh
kelompok-kelompok oligarki ataupun
kadang-kadang ada juga yang mengambil
cangkang alias partai politik yang sudah
punya badan hukum. karena begitu
rumitnya. Padahal harusnya partai lokal
itu mestinya bisa dan punya kursi di DPR
nasional dan maju ke pemilihan presiden.
Ini misalnya terjadi dengan partai DUTRT
di Filipina.
Jadi bukan menciptakan partai lokal
seperti halnya partai lokal di Aceh,
tapi biarkan partai bertumbuh mulai dari
level lokal. Karena nyatanya basis
terpenting partai politik adalah di
daerah, bukan dikreasikan atau didrop
dari Jakarta untuk kemudian dibuatkan
cabang-cabangnya secara performatif.
[Musik]
Emang dia segitu spesialnya sampai dia
ada di rumah lu?
Iya, karena ini satu-satunya warna
abu-abu
di Indonesia.
Di Indonesia.
Perombakan sistem pemilu juga
dibutuhkan.
Kita sekarang punya sistem proporsional
terbuka dan ini harus dievaluasi
karena yang terjadi adalah sistem ini
mendorong kompetisi antar kandidat
secara head to head begitu ya,
gila-gilaan yang ujungnya adalah praktik
politik uang yang brutal sebenarnya di
Dirty Fot salah satunya kami juga
menampilkan brutalnya politik uang pada
saat itu. Dan terakhir kalau bicara
reformasi sistem kepartaian harus ada
pembaruan penyelenggara pemilu. Ini juga
kita bahas panjang waktu itu di Dirty
Food. Seleksi penyelenggara harus
dipisahkan dari intervensi yang sifatnya
partisan. Nah, jadi desainnya mesti kita
bongkar. Tapi yang jelas kita harus
menghasilkan penyelenggara pemilu yang
yang kredibel sehingga nanti seluruh
agenda reformasi pemilu juga akan
berjalan dengan baik. Jadi ee apa yang
harus dirombak dalam hal sistem politik
dan kepartaian ringkasnya tapi tidak
terlalu ringkas karena kita punya enam
poin. Pertama adalah kaderisasi dan
demokratisasi parpol. Kita bongkar.
Kemudian yang kedua, pendanaan partai
politik dan juga dana kampanye. Yang
ketiga, kita harus buka ruang pendirian
parpol yang baru dan organik. Jadi harus
kita bongkar barrier to entry-nya itu
termasuk supaya partai lokal bisa
berdiri. Yang keempat mensyaratkan
minimal jumlah tahun sebagai kader
sebagai syarat penentuan calon
legislatif. Jadi, tidak bisa asal pilih
votetter. Kemudian yang kelima,
perombakan sistem pemilu. Pasti
diskusinya akan jauh lebih panjang dari
ini, tapi intinya adalah kita evaluasi
supaya kita punya sistem yang memperkuat
representasi substantif. Jadi ee kita
punya keterkaitan yang kuat dengan para
wakil, tapi juga meminimalkan biaya
politik. Jadi tidak merajal lela politik
uangnya. Dan yang ketiga membuka peluang
yang besar bagi masyarakat yang selama
ini termarginalkan untuk ikut dalam
politik. Nah, jadi mungkin sistem pemilu
campuran itu perlu kita pertimbangkan.
Nah, dan tentu saja yang keenam adalah
perombakan model seleksi, model desain
institusionalnya maupun model pemilihan
dari penyelenggara pemilu supaya tidak
terlalu diintervensi oleh partai-partai
politik yang justru akan dikelola oleh
para penyelenggara pemilu ini.
danuanya iniara
kita harus bongkar
di sisi yang meredam kemarahan
kita punya anak-anak muda
terus ada
yang ak bergerak untuk mempigara ini
sampai merenggut
10-an kita
ini baru satu kelompok kecil yang ketemu
setiap hari Kamis
di depan Istana Negara tapi ini adalah
sampel Oleh karena sekelompok
yang sebenarnya ingin punya
penyelenggara negara,
ingin punya bangsa yang jauh lebih baik
daripada sekarang. Tapi ruangnya
tertutup
dengan situasi yang mengungkung kita
seperti yang tadi dijelaskan.
Nah, jadi bayangkan pada akhirnya
semua perbaikan sistem pemilu ini akan
menyumbang membuka ruang-ruang untuk
partisipasi politik seperti yang kita
lihat ini. Barangkali untuk
menggambarkannya, saya akan pinjam lagi
ee tablet yang tersedia di sini untuk
menggambarkan bagaimana kita perlu
membongkar hal-hal yang tadi sudah
dijelaskan dari awal sampai akhir. Kita
pasti pertama-tama ketika berpikir
negara biasanya berpikir
penyelenggaranya. kan kita mikirnya
penyelenggaranya. Padahal
kita ngajar juga soal ini bahwa negara
pada awalnya adalah soal warga.
Kalau tidak ada warga tidak akan ada
negara.
Warga inilah yang akan memilih pengurus
negara. Kita sebut saja begitu pengurus
negara. Bukan pemerintah sih sebenarnya
ya. Merah kan ke sana mereka
memerintah-merintah nih.
Mereka harusnya ngurusin kita.
Setuju. Setuju.
Nah, pengurus negara ini kan bisa
dipilih
melalui pemilu dan partai politik.
Tapi apa yang terjadi selama ini? Yang
terjadi adalah ternyata
ini rusak.
Malah pengurus negara punya POV sendiri
yang beda dengan POV kita sebagai warga.
Enggak nyambung
dengan VOV pengurus negara. Mereka
bangunlah itu tadi ototnya,
otaknya
dan ongkos.
Pov point of view ya berarti ya.
Point of view. Saya berusaha pakai
bahasa anak muda banget. Point of
view-nya beda nih cara pandang antara
warga. Untung aja diingetin ya antara
warga dengan pengurus negara tuh beda
sekali karena terputus di sini. Jadi ini
relasinya hilang.
Nah, yang sebenarnya harus kita lakukan
adalah kita bangun lagi sistem pemilu
dan parpol supaya ketersambungan ini
muncul lagi.
Ada istilah bagusnya itu ee ketiadaan
relasi partisipasi apa representasi dan
aspirasi.
Representasi dan aspirasi itu kuncinya.
Itu yang selama ini kita enggak punya
saluran dan ini yang mesti kita bangun.
Kalau
saluran aspirasi dan representasi ini
bisa kita bangun,
tentu saja ada otak juga, ada otot juga,
ada ongkos juga, tapi bukan untuk si
pengurus negara, tapi untuk warga.
Iya. I
kira-kira begitu yang harus kita
lakukan.
Besar sekali pekerjaannya.
Besar sekali.
Saya bahkan bayangkan, Bib, nanti
partai-partainya itu kayak Liga Champion
itu loh.
Jadi lokal itu betul-betul Iya. Jadi
mereka
benar sih. Benar.
Mereka betul-betul menguasai lokal baru
kemudian bisa bertarung di nasional.
Jadi kayak
lokal itu adalah pertarungan pertama
mereka saringan. Kalau mereka sudah
nguasai lokal,
majulah nasional ya.
Majulah nasional ya. Kayak Liga Champion
lah. Hanya peringkat nomor satu baru
kemudian dapat
ked
di sanalah letak MU profesionalnya ya.
Bisa-bisa kita akan memulai perdebatan
sepak bola di sini.
Dulu di film Dirty Vote pertama kami
dianggap terlambat karena kayak baru
ngasih peringatan tentang kecurangan
pemilu hanya 3 hari sebelum pencoblosan.
Bahkan kami dianggap punya agenda
politik tertentu.
Sekarang kami merekam dirty vote kedua 4
tahun sebelum pemilu dan pilpres. Hari
ini belum ada tim sukses apalagi capres
dan Cawapres.
Di film pertama kami mengungkap bahwa
strategi mengakali pemilu sudah
dirancang sebelumnya oleh pihak yang
sedang berkuasa. Mereka mengakali otak
lewat aturan dan Mahkamah Konstitusi.
Mereka mengerahkan otot lewat aparat dan
penyelenggara pemilu. Lalu memakai
ongkos negara untuk membelih dukungan
lewat politik gentong babi.
Ini ibarat sepak bola di mana aturan
main dan seluruh wasit telah
dikondisikan untuk memenangkan salah
satu tim. Dan kita sebagai suporter
sekali lagi hanya bisa bersorak,
bergembira, bahkan gontok-gontokan untuk
sesuatu yang sebenarnya hasilnya sudah
ditentukan.
Nah, di film kedua ini kami ingin
menunjukkan bahwa siapapun kelak tak
perlu capek-capek lagi mengakali setiap
pemilu.
Sebab seluruh sistem kompetisi telah
diprogram otomatis
untuk memenangkan tim yang menguntungkan
dan didukung oligarki.
Sistem ini bahkan menghancurkan tim lain
sejak dini. Mereka tak akan bisa
membangun stadion karena sistem
keuangannya sudah dikuasai. Mereka
bahkan tak cukup punya lapangan untuk
anak-anak bermain bola karena semua
tanah juga sudah dikuasai.
Tim manaun tak akan sempat punya
bibit-bibit pemain unggul karena mereka
akan dipaksa bekerja bersama-sama dengan
oligarki untuk bertahan hidup. Desain
kecurangan berevolusi menjadi sistem
politik yang korup dan tak adil tapi sah
dan formal di mata negara. Karena
hakikatnya yang dibajak adalah sistem
kenegaraan itu sendiri. di kampus kami
menyebutnya state capture.
Jadi ini bukan tentang rezim Prabowo
Gibran semata. Ini jauh melampaui rezim
hari ini. Mereka hanya semacam penyemai
benih yang kelak siapapun dapat
memanfaatkannya sepanjang memilih jalan
anti demokrasi dan menguntungkan
oligarki. Inilah lingkaran setan yang
harus kita putus. Untuk mempertahankan
lingkaran setan ini, mental culas dan
tahan malu saja tak cukup. Sistem ini
akan bertahan lama jika kita menganggap
semuanya normal.
Tidak. Ini sama sekali tidak normal.
Ini bukan sistem bernegara yang
dibayangkan oleh para pendiri bangsa
kita dan oleh mereka yang rela berkorban
agar kita bisa merdeka.
Kita perlu terus membangun gerakan
sosial tanpa menunggu niat baik dari
para elit. Tak ada juru selamat, tak ada
Mesi-atunya
juru selamat adalah diri kita sendiri
dan itu harus dilakukan secara
bersama-sama. Kami dari generasi X hidup
lebih awal untuk mengamati rezim demi
rezim berganti
dan sebagai ilmuwan serta pengajar
merasakan betul bahwa kita sedang
berjalan mundur tapi masa depan adalah
milik generasi milenial Gen dan para
penerusnya. Maka siapapun yang memiliki
keresahan yang sama, ayo berbuat
sesuatu. Kita tak harus jadi mahasiswa
atau pelajar hanya untuk bergerak.
Generasi baru yang ada di ormas-ormas
doronglah perombakan. Tinggalkan
kekuatan lama yang terbukti hanya
memanfaatkan organisasi untuk melayani
segelintir kekuasaan atau memperkaya
diri. Anak-anak muda di partai politik
yang sebenarnya juga korban dalam sistem
ini. Ayo mulai mendobrak otoritarianisme
di dalam internal partai sendiri.
Kawan-kawan anggota TNI, Polri atau ASN
yang sudah lelah melayani sistem yang
toksik ini, mari bersuara, berserikat,
berkolaborasi, temukan cara sendiri
untuk ikut dalam gelombang arus
perubahan. Dua dari tiga orang ini juga
ASN. Justru karena merasa digaji oleh
rakyat, mereka melakukan sesuatu,
berkolaborasi dengan orang-orang yang
ada di belakang kamera ini. Kita harus
mengubah cara berpikir, lebih kreatif,
berimajinasi, lalu membangun kekuatan
politik baru. Kalau yang lama tak bisa
juga dibenahi, tinggalkan ramai-ramai.
Mulailah dengan partai, ormas atau
organisasi yang baru. Meski skalanya
lebih kecil, tapi itulah modal kita. Ini
permainan ronde panjang dan tak ada yang
instan. Tapi harus kita mulai sekarang.
Kita perlu regenerasi elit politik,
regenerasi elit ormas, bahkan regenerasi
tentara, polisi, dan aparat sipil
negara. termasuk memberikan kebebasan
kepada kampus dan sekolah dari ketakutan
yang merampas kreativitas dan daya
berpikir.
Oleh sebagian orang mungkin film Dirty
Vot pertama dianggap gagal karena tak
mengubah hasil pemilu. Tentu saja sebuah
film tak mungkin mengalahkan triliunan
dana bansos, serangan fajar atau
mobilisasi aparat negara. Sebuah film
tak mungkin mengalahkan lembaga survei,
buzer, influencer, bahkan media yang
memilih bekerja melayani lingkaran setan
ini. Dan memang bukan tugas sebuah film
untuk mengubah nasib sebuah bangsa. Anda
tahulah apa yang kami maksud.
[Musik]
Ya, mau tidak mau terpaksa kita tetap
harus organisasikan. Ya, kampus
ada baiknya tetap danus
[Musik]
Tuhan
[Tepuk tangan]
[Musik]
Doa saya kira ee semua orang punya
kepercayaannya masing-masing dan doa
tidak perlu dalam satu agama tertentu.
Silakan kita berdoa kepada apa yang kita
percayai.
Semoga yang kita percayai itu membantu
kita. Silakan teman-teman doanya
dimulai.
Doa tidak pernah selesai, tapi kita
cukupkan untuk hari ini.
Oke, terima kasih teman-teman. Tepuk
tangan untuk semua. Salam bekerja.
Let's do it. Let's do it. Let's rock.
Let's rock.
Silakan yang mau ke WC. Kita punya waktu
5 menit.
5 menit kita start jam
aja. Mudah.
Jangan nangis, jangan nangis, jangan
nangis.
Bahwa ada penambahan enam qodam baru
sehingga kodam kita sekarang berjumlah
21 kodam di seluruh Indonesia.
segede itu kelihatan
[Musik]
terembus dalam lubang jalananilaskanak
asik coy
enggak asik coy coy
Terjalan
mimpi yang indah
lelah
[Musik]
Yeah.